there we go the chat
okay it's gonna be crowded it's gonna be
Rowdy so you tell me are we live yeah or
we are live but we're chilling because
we're letting Dustin do its thing it's
thing his thing um but I'm excited all
right there we go I see everyone they're
saying I'm frozen but we're not frozen
we're live everyone's happy I see Tina
in there I do see flip uh teacher 96
always representing I've got good Red
Wine Sign up for win.com uh look we're
here Rip's con Tyler's in the cut show
Tyler kind of do like a get oh look yeah
Tyler you come in in important moments
okay let's do that we are here everybody
Welcome to An Evening Edition of be
should we make this an official episode
should no always they're all unofficial
absolutely we've always been an alpha
we're still in Alpha tonight all right
look right off the bat where's the top
right corner I know a lot of you have
been wanting to be a part of this uh and
so uh oh Dustin we okay yeah you can
just that okay cool um there are slots
available for our up four upcoming
events tonight is a special event
because I'm here and obviously when con
and rips do it they do well if you liked
what con for one so far yeah if you
we'll talk about Tri Simon in a little
bit but let's let's just understand is
this working you know tonight we'll be
doing some important Zack Wilson two
seconds left moments but big Dame
Lillard trade huge
huge oh I like this I can oh Dustin
you're doing very good Dustin flew with
me we want I don't you guys know this
went to Utah I crushed silicon slopes
today with Ryan Smith the Utah Jazz
owner crush it flew right back to be
here tonight for this special night
because I'm in the mood
yes no guys I'm really in the mood I'm
in the mood I just need everybody to
know I need all 270 of you first of all
everyone has to share this link once I
get to 500 in here I'm just going to
start giving away ridiculous [__] like
we' got stuff to give out like let's get
people excited right off the bat look at
this if you don't know what's happening
in the culture
ohone can't see them the ogs are in the
building Sun big trade today trouty wine
and be friends Legend and Phil Toronto
funding
Falcon but look look we're
no no I'm going to give this away today
but we're going to build up to the Dion
this is prime this is hot look people
want this we got the Skeletor collab
which is over Conor's right shoulder
there's a lot going on I'm drinking wine
and I'm telling you we're at 310 people
right now I feel like a lot of people
should know how to share the link to
this should know how to get this out
when this hits 500 I'm just GNA start
giving away ridiculous [__] I'm gonna
give away a young
boy I'm gonna give away but look tonight
what I really want to do as well in the
comments how many of you do not own a
vend nft we're going to do vri's cards
tonight heavy but say if say not me not
me there we go say not me I think
tonight I'm gonna give away some be
nft and we're gonna give con theier
service because a lot of people here
don't even know how to own an nft so if
you win tonight Khan will get your info
y right y we'll then know how to get to
them the app yep and then we'll set up a
zoom for coner service of how you can
set up a wallet wow and then I will send
it to you I'm going to give away some
vend series two that are sitting in my
wallet me and Andy talked earlier I was
like I want to give away a vf1 but all
of them are in a hot are in a cold
wallet they're right they're they're
like really secure and I'm like so
spooked these days I'm just like let's
not touch it but I might have one in a
hot wallet I might buy actually you know
what I'm gonna buy one that's what I
we'll figure it out but we're giving
away a VF one tonight wow wow wow yes
and a good one a go wow or I might buy
one I'll decide you told me that a card
went too much but no we're gonna go
crazy tonight but we're at 366 I'm not
doing any of that until we at 500 I'm
give away all the other [__] no be from
ZFS how sick is that that's [__]
crazy you you haven't seen it yet but
you saw the holding I know but you saw
the announcement yesterday I saw the
announcement yeah Masters that put in
the screen Ty get it in here the masters
of the UN it doesn't live reaction yeah
the Masters of the Universe open it this
the
skelator tell them what it is tell them
what it is this is it's coming out
October 6 Andy look at the back you
gotta look at the wine nerds in the back
there's so much going on here talking to
everybody here everybody right here
please go to my Twitter download for
everybody here these are all my other
live streams hi
everybody Lin Donnie on
YouTube all of you Twitter please go to
my Twitter this is madness to get the
link if you want to get in here you
can't get free [__] for everyone here on
LinkedIn I see a ton of people on
LinkedIn ton of people on YouTube all
the free [__] can only happen on
Fanatics live the Fanatics Live app so
everyone here all of you what I put down
here in the bottom go to Gary V's
Twitter to join the stream go to my
Twitter right now download the app
do
oh man the chat's we got more viewers
but everyone's getting crazy and we
haven't even started yeah that is you
know how much it is $45 it's a [__]
October 6 at the
back actually give me that I want to
show everybody on my my social media
stream this is not even the fanatic
stream this is what everyone's getting
crazy about the uh the Skeletor
collaboration we're doing with Eman
super excited but everybody again all of
the thousands of you in this get your
ass to the Fanatics live we're already
at 423 big number let's give away the
Dion prime time it is prime time let's
give away the Dion right now for
everybody's here for the first time
you're gonna see something pop up right
now to enter free to enter somebody just
gave you this for free how much is
follow how much is
this let's get the coms rolling let's
get listen I'm giving away free [__]
tonight uh I want to tell all of you
there are ways to buy slots to get into
our Pack openings beat the boss which is
me versus you ton we're doing that
tonight yeah sports edition all right
Sports oh I was gonna do this and that
but
I free [__] right now in 39 seconds one
of you right off the top is getting
something free it's huge here silicon
slopes was amazing Kyle I enjoyed it I
yes I wasn't yes I'm back in New York I
was in Utah five minutes ago I was in
Utah five minutes ago I know a bunch of
you saw me there live in Utah at the
Jazz Arena but no I'm back in New York
this is how we do it it's EAA life over
here guys we maximize the I should be
the only person not wearing this nobody
knows how to drive down iida like me 75
bucks probably underpriced but there's a
lot of
them nobody knows no one knows about
that Jets quarterback Wilson that's
right if you're joining for the first
time we hit two seconds and at that
point any time we hit two seconds give a
huge shout out to number two Zack Wilson
because we are cheering him on [__]
every who's dragging him down we're GNA
stun the Chiefs put Taylor [__] Swift
in the building this Sunday night on
prime time Sunday Night Football that is
not my official
prediction who won three I Saw Three
Heads creating I want to wait for the
chat I want wait for the chat won
go I
like I love when an OG wins all right
we're at 485 this means I'll give away
crazy [__] when I hit 500 I'll probably
get excited and run to my office and
grab something expensive and just give
it away but real quick let's set up the
four upcoming live streams three
upcoming live streams people here are a
lot of new people at 485 wow yep can we
explain that they can buy slots for Pack
openings beat the boss like can you rips
can you really explain and I won't
interrupt you when that hits 500 because
that's probably gonna happen while
you're explaining explain [__] to us
rips be the explainer I'm the excitement
and the looks you're the explainer and
the youth Conor is the operations and
the charm let's go love that nice and 58
518 I'm not giving away anything free
until we hit 600 nothing before I
Nothing free until 600 before I explain
how are you feeling about all the rumors
that Taylor worth is only going because
you're going it's not true she's dating
Kelsey I don't know if you're paying
attention uh but she'll be in the
building I know what's happening and I'm
I'm incred what
I'm aware D that happened four minutes
ago we acknowledged 518 four minutes ago
but but I know you're running prop you
know production back there so I just
said I'm not doing anything until 600
anyway again all of you here in my other
social get your ass to my Twitter
there's links to the how download the
app you got to get in here the real in
here which is the Fanatics Live app
where we're gonna be doing a ton of
stuff but explain [__] RI all right bu
spots have they been buy Spot got
got the friends cards tonight's break is
going to be spontaneous on the spot
there's nothing someone could buy right
now for this break it's GNA pop up on
your screen that's how fnatic's live is
going to work tonight we're live
tomorrow Connor and I that break is
completely sold out we have like seven
personal boxes that we listed watch this
hold on how many of you in the chat want
a spot for the next week's all the
things you could buy the different spots
right there yeah see a lot of a lot of
them want spots because they feel like
we might have to list more let's see if
we sell them out but where do they find
them what are they buying what's next
week so this is your screen this is
going to be way too confusing but this
is we're good this is this is your
screen right
now if you press on V friends on the top
right and press the icon first you have
to hit follow that's true go need 1.6k
we need 1.7k follow I don't see 2K you
have to hit follow first good want
follow you'll see our show schedule so
we're live right now we've got tomorrow
Monday and Thursday if you click on each
stream Monday's fun it's my pack Monday
personal packs we have like 200 personal
packs up right so that's the most
accessible way to get into the vriends
world if you press the little storefront
on that
stream you'll see we have one format
that's sold out then we have 44 and 49
spots left for pack bundles it's two
packs so it's like a nice way to start
off and they're all available here you
just press one 50 bucks and get started
you have 97 of those okay on Monday and
then that seem like too much clicking to
buy [__] well it's because it's not on
this stream if they could buy on maybe
they could buy it in the future if it
has to be a different grow like if right
now I tell you to throw up beat the boss
sports card Edition yeah and I threw
that up right now they would just it
would be easy right Onre can we do that
yes sir so do that right now right now
people are people don't give a [__]
about next week we're in an instant
gratification Society rips people bu SH
now and they want to go we open a pack
of feed friends and it's me vers you
beat the boss I'm the boss we're gonna
be going right like right here right now
live and we're going to go we're going
to open it and if they beat me and be
friends card game they will get the very
expensive cards for my collection like a
Barry Sanders rookie like a Troy aie
whoa all that's a bundle of three that's
a big shot it's a bundle of three got it
like a Devin Booker that's for Nate Nate
DAV Booker rookie this keep waiting
there there's more you gotta no ball
there's a bunch of big cards here L to
the next
one go good to list so here Beat the
Boss no you got to beat the boss you got
this is we're having fun here
it's the customer pack against Gary's
pack hold on real quick explain before
people buy something right now which is
happening right now all right the rules
you list it it's called Beat the Boss
we're gonna open packs of be friends you
get a pack I get a pack whoever gets the
highest card wins if you win you get my
cards Y and the actual slab like like a
they're going be to see they're going to
be a to one they're entering for you'll
see the names so you can pick which one
you want if you lose and I have the
highest card you still get your four
cards that's what you're buying but I
keep my Vince Carter rookie and I keep
my cards yes that's right so this is me
vers you I'm the boss you're trying to
beat me we're about to list these right
now how much are the slots $60 a piece
$60 a piece like Luca
prism it's real Stu there some under
price no I know what we did here people
know these are educated people Everyone
Knows here we I know we're at 636 yeah
I'm gonna give away crazy [__] I
promised you I told you if we hit 700
people
I will give away crazy [__] that's what
I so I understand that we're 636 but you
need to share the links that keep
sharing and I will give away crazy [__]
everybody on all my social medias if
you're trying to figure out what's going
on go to my Twitter get into the app
right now download Fanatics app this is
how you gonna get free [__] otherwise
you're just gonna be watching on
LinkedIn and Facebook and YouTube like
right now and you're not gonna be able
to get this and I want to give away free
stuff I'm gonna do stuff for you please
go to my Twitter right now uh I've got
all the links uh for the way to get the
Fanatics live
and let's do that okay so how many slots
are we selling right now 13 13 so
everyone get ready this is gonna go very
fast who's got the quick fingers who's
got the quick fingers shoot it bang
let's go beat the boss is it live it's
live it's live we're gonna be sleep
we'll let it we'll let it it's sold out
oh it's gone they're all
so okay that's true yep zero 13 spots
remaining let's why don't you guys set
up okay let's clap it up for go who's
got the hot fingers
baby 654 the live listen we're crushing
on Fanatics just a call out to all the
other fanatic shows that are going on
right now we love you we're cheering for
you but we're beating your [__] ass
you got 30 people you got nine you got
26 we're here at 654 on our way to 700
let's share the links share the link to
this 700 gets me to run into my office
and get a ton of free [__] we're going
to go crazy stuff V friend's nfts are
going to be giving away out
tonight and I'm [__] excited about
that all right so here we go all right
so you're gonna get 13 packs that's your
box I just shuffled them go 13 packs
what is Dustin doing oh the
boss what produc now we're gonna get 13
packs I'm gonna represent let's go by
the way real quick real quick I'm
drinking great wine from win Tex can
everybody in the chat put in winx.com I
feel like some of the 600 people here
are not signed up and Sasha vaynerchuk
is watching at home in New Jersey and if
I don't do this plug for winetext.com
he's gonna be mad at me please sign up
for winex look at the links they know
what to do actually who's been signed up
for winex and please leave a couple of
sentences or comments about winex people
don't realize what the [__] is going on
in winex don't worry Conor know check it
out we're gonna open at the same time we
got the boss and the customer live on
the screen I bought like six good cases
of good [__] thank you should we run
another giveaway so all the new people
in the room can get uh yeah we got we
got to figure that out but first we got
to do Beat the Boss this is my packs
this is yours this is mine okay so I'm
representing the customer it says it it
says the boss and the customer
okay we're gonna rip together I know
it's fine I'm ready who's up first on
Beat the Boss pops drops pops
drops
up Brook what's good welcome first time
who's first time here I need to see
first time in here please put in first
time I want to say what's up for first
time Tommy F what's good J this going
fast Jesus Christ Cactus success Insider
what's good skizo you're in the building
Sammy in my seat I think this is Landon
is a veteran that's what I was gonna say
Landon's won a bunch of a oh bogles a
good time overseer very nice bunch of
new people thank you for joining vriends
fanatic live where this might be the
most stream event I've never seen higher
than this in a stream neither
I don't like what's going on here we're
stuck oh we went down from 671 to 666
the devil wow that is the devil do we
have a resilient Red Devil here
somewhere only in pin format what about
pin format oh we haven't we pulled we
pulled epic who's a vs holder and an OG
please put in the chat that you're a
vriends maxi you know everything you've
been to vcon I need to see who's a
vriends maxi put in Maxi put in Maxi we
have a m I just got to get a sense of
who's in here all right we of a major
Alpha drop big as many people know these
you want to do it now no no I don't want
to do it yet but people don't we're
gonna oh I want to sell don't say
anything Tyler you know nothing Tyler
Tyler you've been in a 137 PM cave for
two years do not just jump out of it and
start blowing up my
Alpha these are collectible pins show
pull up your all let's do the should we
do the pack why don't we do the pack
break start with Pops I want to do seven
things at once
what's how my brain works I do seven
things at once I'm sorry Alex was revie
the legal forms Tyler talking about the
influencers listen Nate fun we gotta
talk about golf we gotta talk about
Foundation Andy we proba we're pretty
caught up right we don't have anything
to all right why don't we do pop pops
and Dro is up he's battling for the
Akuna PSA 10 rookie card he's he's hot
right now I think a nice [__] H pops
and drops if you I want to see if people
are in for pops or if they're in for the
boss please leave a comment right now
pops or boss pops or boss I'm the boss
[__] the pop all about the one highest
score in your pack pops you're looking
for foils it goes up to 75 and then
there's multipliers with the Rarity so
you're looking for single highest
everybody pops is killing me we're going
we're going here we
go pops I've got your pack Gary's the
boss with his there's
mine here we go it's all about the
single highest score should we flip him
or you want to do one one the time
57 60 is winning pops has 60 is the
highest come on pops 64
64 goes to the buyer Ty goes to P Ty
goes to the we're good people around
here I got here we
go oh no let's go Pops I gotta get used
to this 73 on the harpi oh this is way
Jo I know what there's almost 300
characters at MV friends the harpic the
Tho threeh horned harpic is the only
character that is a madeup character
everything else you know it's a warrior
it's a trooper it's an ant it's an
elephant it's you have one more chance
to get higher than a 74 pops one this is
devastating I'm very
upset pops takes it with the final card
oh oh same card wow same card magic but
73 is the highest score out of both
packs he wins all eight cards God
[__] damn it and the aunia PSA 10 God
damn it let's clap it up for
pops guys you're not here to fool around
trouty fil let's clap it up for pops
let's go
pop it you lost I
lost all right well I'll be better does
this doesn't zoom out right it's okay
we're good we'll be better we'll be next
up we'll be better everyone we see your
next up is the bread he's going to top
right now because it's the Cowboys Aman
PSA 10 rookie card hold on let's stop
right now all 685 of you have to figure
out how to get a link from this and
tweet it out text your buddies hit up
your sports card friends your nft
friends your collectible Friends start
sharing this this needs to get to 700
I'm not giving anybody anything 685
nobody's G anything I'm gonna take
things back I'm not gonna send this [__]
to Pops I don't give a [__] to Alex I'm
kidding I'm kidding all
rightow are H what the Cowboys are hot
they lost out Cardinals but they're
goingon to beat the [__] out of the
Patriots
Aman PSA 10 for the bread so pumped the
Cowboys lost this week because I knew
they were gonna have a let back game
because I knew that the Giants and jets
are not with their so now that they lost
this game they're gonna go into this New
England game much more serious so I I'm
like pump the Cardinals beat them plus
Josh dos Vayner Sports all right do this
Aman can you beat the boss who we
playing against the bread the bread the
bread who's rooting for the bread who's
voting for The Boss Say bread if you're
cheering for bread here
say boss if you're cheating for the boss
me putting it on the pack might be a
good play I one tonight record other
night was n n four the other night n and
four that was hot the other record nine
and five now they just did a big bread R
62 68 the
alpha very appropriate alligator yes
it's very appropriate because tonight we
are dropping Alphas when it comes to
pins if you want to look at pins uh rips
if you can grab your phone and maybe
pull up completed items on pins I don't
think people understand what's happening
on the
bay on eBay on eBay right now on the
[__] Bay what's going on with vriends
pins Tyler people don't
understand look at this burn Island
surprise we surprise people with a
limited edition burn island people that
burned one of their nfts burn look at
these $150 pins yeah those are fire they
[__] these are from vcon nice lot 15
there's not that many so because people
also really collect them heavy is the
other thing lot of a lot of disc
look at the gift Go Buck
75 this is the boxes from vcon 555
crossed out best offer National pins 125
the parrot 22 so we've got pins we're
gonna sell some pins we're gonna open
some pins tonight National Pin and the
Olympics are coming Nation how much your
Olympic how much your National pins go
for
hundo so tonight how much are these be
fluid these are going to be 40 bucks it
might be 45 want to say 45 oh rips is
looking for a little five AC let's go 50
should we go I was debating between 40
and 50 we can do should we go
50 let's go 50 on these how many slots
do we have five five so we're gonna put
up you got them ready yep we're gonna
sell these five we got five of these pin
boxes we sell
half I know what we have to do boys I
run operations I know what we have to do
we open up these packs I know what we're
doing but we're GNA put up these pins
shortly because the alpha alligator is
very important tonight how do you get on
this I have a lot of empathy for your
[__] but listen to me I'm going to
use my will and accomplish what I want
here we're gonna talk pins tonight
because we have a [__] bomb a bomb
it's not just pins is the other part
right we do like being super around him
that's true we like being super look at
how happy Nate is huge son's trade today
got a little depth I mean you you got
rips next to you too yeah rips is he's
not he's a he's a he's a Greek Freak fan
he's bu fan I'm not pump for The Bu I
told him I told him earlier he literally
didn't believe me and then he looks at
me again two seconds later and he like
starts screaming like a child funny I'm
winning so far I'm winning so far the
alpha alligator 68 is too much I don't
who am I going
against can't beat me bread will not
beat a
68 oh 67 for bread doesn't do it
dragonly doesn't do it oh a double
flipped double f not beat it and did not
beat it wow let's hear it from the boss
the boss one in one that's one in one W
nice all right so bre gets BR gets his
four cards I keep my
Troy stays stays let's go on to the next
are we doing giveaways and other fun
stuff no on to next on to the next on to
next we got a Booker I'm gonna read
while you guys where's the Kyle kma
collection Jordan I don't know I gotta
look uh the firefighters they mod loose
very nice good to see you you can win
something Mike stay but we're doing a
bunch somebody bought two gift goats
today that was very when are we talking
beon 2024 tomorrow whoa let's go Alpha
drop here right now
Andy I just told him that tomorrow we
are dropping the Von details date
location that's
it wow uhuh
oh snap so that's right Von hello
everybody great to see everybody MAF
everybody's watching right here on
Twitch please say what's up what's going
on Jared Johnson just asked in LinkedIn
we are live on Fanatics live please go
to my Twitter and check out what's going
on here there's a ton going on we're
giving away a ton of free [__] here on
Fanatics live we are pumping and excited
about what's going on with be friends
we're doing s tonight we're doing we're
doing collectible there's Deon Booker
rookie here big one up next one how much
is
this for sure amazing we're doing
Fanatics live I'm giving away a ton of
free [__] we're gonna hit 700 viewers
here if people work a little bit out of
the 656 that are
here now I'm gonna go away tons of free
[__] so everybody here on Yo Jared so
Andre Donna please please Daniel please
go to I love you back baly cop uh please
go to Twitter and check out how to get
on here on the live on Fanatics live and
big shout out to everybody here who's on
Fanatics live Vegas PS 3 rich Christian
Gomez Batman the Greek NYC true love Jay
woly e lari glas guy Tori they're in the
[__] building tonight yes what are
you guys talking about back there andy
the trade all right the trade all right
let's open this pack the dudo Texas ogv
friend he was with us at the national
he's looking for a Booker PSA 10 one of
the cards I'm gonna win this the boss so
who's who am I up against the dudo Texas
the dudo who wants the dudo to win and
who wants the boss say doooo or
B can I get some more wine over here I
need more wine so that I give away
obnoxious things
tonight someone says Gary V loses I
don't see it happening I don't see it
either this feels like a there's foils
we haven't hit a foil yet yes there's
inserts in here everyone here we go
ready it's [__]
over wow
dudo [__] over patient Panda coming
in one of the KY be friends a 70 second
highest score in the whole game it only
goes to 75 watch this
Auto and I'm gonna give away this Auto
free after we're done with this pack
let's go only if rip stuns me with a
foil insert and wins this pack that nuts
at 651 on
now it's still 64
only not big enough not big enough
dudo it only Texas not big enough it
only is a 25% boost because it's a rare
the lowest Rarity still good I love this
it's a great card it's a at least he's
still getting it it's like kind of
getting a bit of a color match he's
getting it it's a great card that's a
nice color match we can still get
something crazy but it's not going to
happen now you're dead dead 60 by the
way has anybody pay attention to my pack
my pack is common sense cow Diamond H
hen and patient Panda one of the great
packs of all time Judo your last shot
woke walrus 56 Tanda I get Deon Booker
rookie card big hold Nate we could talk
about
that live deals you got 200 bucks in
cash on you I'll sell to you under Mar
for cash um oh you want to give away the
auto the panda it's time to give away
the panda let's C it up for the free
giveaway let's go
look at
everybody for all the new followers all
you Jason Weber this is why you brand
Daniel Santos still seconds all of you
have to get on the Fanatics Live app
it's in my Twitter which is why it's
linked get over to the Fanatics Live app
get over here this is where the pre
stuff happens it happens on Fanatics
live gotta be following to enter gotta
be
following a quick follow follow Corner
follow
let's go chat love it chat let's
go diamonds what's good what's up what's
up who's up next Ricky Martinez how we
doing KOB
though somebody's getting this patient
Panda auto is a monster this is a real
card for everybody's paying attention
this is you think this you get this
graded cgc PSA like couple hundred bucks
right yeah easy I mean it's a real
[__] It's On The Rise Like It's On
The Rise it's a really big
that's right if you're joining for the
first time every time we're down to two
seconds on a thing we yell out Zack
Wilson number two New York
Jets let's see it's got to be spinning
it's got to be spinning who won go to
see who
won who won the
we
for
weeded all right theed I get it not and
this is go all right so this is going to
the weed here we go the weed big hit the
weed's just chilling here hasn't even
bought a slot gets a free $200 card if
he grades it
probably the next beat the ball are you
[__] kidding me Kobe rookie guys I
need an 8C moment of silence for one of
the all-time great cultural human and
athletes Co
Let's do an 8C moment of silence please
here we
go thank you everybody let's cough it
[Applause]
up let's get first of all like what an
icon like really one of the great really
really really one of the great regrets
of my life that I didn't get the
Serendipity of really chopping it up
with him because I really admire that
mindset you know all of you this is an
inner circle for me here behind the
scenes and on screen you guys know what
I think about competition and positive
competition and just devastating anyway
this is really remarkable I'm this is
from my Personal Collection a Kobe
Bryant rookie card and this is what
tonight's all about you know we're
actually selling slots for future uh
streams you can find that in top right
corner top right corner press V friends
look at our schedule on each break you
click you'll see like a bunch of slots
available after we give this away we'll
show people how to do it on the phone
then um because I how many people want
to buy a slot for future
uh streams next week that are on right
now and yeah lot want to get it yeah
people don't know how to do it so we're
gon a lot so let's we'll show them that
in a minute um but let's do this Kobe
who am I going up against with shout out
to whoever got there go go let's let's
clap it up for gob's fat pants it's a
big one I'll be honest with you I
desperately don't want to lose this one
I do not want to lose Gob [__] you here
we go
all right go Gob I represent your pack
Gary's got his own can you beat the boss
is the question I'm the boss and I'm not
going down here we go bam let's [__]
go right up the back the
flamingo 72 gonna be hard to beat big
one keeping my Kobe [__] let's see what
we got for right flamingo in your
[__] mouth glob go what the [__] your
name is pump did not want to lose this
53 god let's talk about the siis of duck
has anybody else been Mesmer so I don't
know if anybody's paying attention I
think the decisive duck has the
potential to rare roll at it like I
think decisive duck is winning hearts
and Minds on a daily basis and if we
come out with the right song the right
animation the right I think this [__]
guy if we get like people are me look at
this not TI pay attention look at the
face look at the face if you look at the
sis of duck long
enough no you fall in love you remember
like in junior high or high
school what do matter no I'm trying to
make a point here do you remember like
think back to like a girl in high school
that at first you weren't like oh my God
I need to go out with Karen Thompson but
you had English class with her and like
after a while like you know yeah
September you're like I don't want to go
out with Karen Thompson but by April
you're like you're like writing Karen
Thompson on and a heart on your [__]
forehand like that's what the sze of
duck is I I believe what show yeah like
the size of duck is like
everything zoom in there D like do it
proper what's this blurry [__] there we
look at this keep looking at the size of
duck keep looking at the size of duck is
or is it I think it's the eyes
the the hair is top I'm telling you like
the size of duck well he gets to keep
the card which is great that's good okay
here we go I'm telling you decisive duck
is the sleeper for all the N this this
is B the third card this would be the
hit that could get an insert that could
get over 72 if not Gob I'm keeping my
[__] cob
go let's do it 65 oh my god there he is
the resilient Red
Devil Red Devil double 72 resilience
baby I got one more shot I got one more
shot
holy [__] what a pack imagine wow that's
a huge rookie card it's a rookie card
there was a series one of V we'll show
you that tonight at some point on the
phone yeah V series 1 cards are insane
there was only a thousand boxes only
10,000 cards crazy yeah they're like six
five six five 6,000 a box right now for
only 10 cards series ones are crazy
there was 15 new characters when we
dropped the be friends nfts that the
resilient Red Devil was kind of like the
star of those 15 kind of like the black
cat of that the Black Cat's the big one
in our world so this is a huge card very
sought after and it's a rookie card
whereas most of our 250 plus characters
rookie cards is in series one 15
characters have rookie cards in series
two this is an important Alpha that I
still think the eBay Market is slightly
behind it
yep chance I got a bit get over a
72 gonna get it done so you moov to two
in one now Gary's now two in one let me
keep
my you're coming [__] home cob actually
you know what no yeah you know what what
happened was I watched when this Kobe
came up
right I'm coming up an idea yeah little
Idea Idea yeah maybe all right con I'm
proud of you thank you we
have
okay I saw a lot of people in the chat
get excited about this card and look I
was early on cards like I was I've been
on in cards forever but I was ear on
this next wave and the reality is I have
a lot of Kobe rookie cards and so I do
think that if you look at the chat like
people really want this and wouldn't it
be nice if you just join us on this
special night we're at 688 I did say
that I would do big things if I got to
700 there's a part of me that would be
like should we wait to
700 but but it's 88 it's double Kobe
jersey number yeah I like that feel like
I'm a nice guy I think so and I think we
should give this away for free right
here right now to one of the great
people I think we should give this away
for free for to someone in the chat
right now and
again you know ARP two black socks
sherle all of you on Facebook LinkedIn
twitch that I see here in my Simo cast
please get over to Twitter download the
app I'm telling you get over here here
[__] it let's give it away give it away
we're giving away Kobe it's live
baby somebody is going home tonight in
the next 51 seconds with a brand new
Kobe Bryant mint n PSA Bowman's best
rookie it's a beast it's a [__] beast
look at look at Andy Andy wishes first
he wishes it was W it was a 1980
Wolverine rookie but he's still excited
look at this
look no I think somebody's gonna
get look how excit look it's late it's
9:41 PM Eastern people earned it by
keeping showing up tonight there's
almost 700 people here
Andy [__] what so seven oh seven away
I'm really excited about this I'm so
happy that somebody just randomly came
here tonight poured a glass of tea or
wine or vodka if it was a tough day
joined us de deed to get into the Z
Wilson that's right if you're joining us
right now every time there's two seconds
left on a free giveaway we yell Zack
Wilson number two on the Jets loud
somebody's getting this right now you
got a big idea crazy I've never seen
your face like this somebody just won a
Kobe Bryant rookie card here for fre
laser
laser here we
go KH I know you're brainstorming but I
need you to be oper
your operations and charm you're the OC
you're M you're M Barton you're the OC
you're operations and charm remember yes
sir laser l e z e r
wow uh oh uh oh put some really good
stuff in here too no I don't give a [__]
about this [__] I'm going right into my
office right now which is right over
there show the office got some stuff to
your left too yeah there's the office
people know the office I'm going in the
office I don't want to give away that
I'm giving away something [__]
bananas right now I'll be right
back also we gotj next on Beat the Boss
Gary's looking I'll show you guys
hopefully the Stillson spots left if not
we'll get more posted afterwards but
here's how you can do stream I think
tomorrow stream sold out so here's here
we are we're
live V friends on the top right corner
press that emblem oh press that emblem
Banas press
friends first
we only raised 100 since more then you
have you have our show schedule here you
have our show schedule I can probably
follow Gary into the office too but us
for
purchasing and then Monday we'll check
we have 27 and 47 spots on
Monday oh my God I don't
isev how much
is I'll look it up I can look it
up yeah it's a good grade
[__] this is no [__] like look
watch I guarantee people like hold yeah
this is this is [__] worth a fuckload
of money lot I think know this is
definitely I look it up 9.6 9.6 yeah
this a [__] monster I don't think I
want give this
away crazy I'll give Ryan R's phone
number
[Laughter]
instead The Punisher it's called I'll
find it before anyone
else let me see the
cover New Mutants 98 this isil's first
appearance [__] I mean uh notevil
[__] uh oh Deadpool deadpol oh this
is
bad it's huge this is this is over 500
bucks yeah it's over 500 500 there's one
at 610 right now bitting and it's there
like white page there's all this stuff
yeah six 600 bucks plus all right we're
giving away [__] oh my God
man dead first appear I said I was going
to go wild tonight you are joking no
doubt you are buying that back shortly
in like got JJ's in the I'm [__] pump
JJ's in the build look at that smile
look at that [__] face live live
let's go let's go who wants this 709 in
the chat who [__] wants this Deadpool
[__] first appearance comic let's go
we're 50 seconds away from somebody
getting hyped as [__] wow it's got a lot
of potential dude it's a huge [__]
comic yeah people are excited I'm
telling all of you that are on all these
other platforms please get over to
Fanatics live you're literally hanging
out on LinkedIn and Facebook and all
this other [__] please go to my Twitter
download the app get in here with us
it's [__] free [__] we're going crazy
we're going crazy all you got to do is
follow to enter it's that simple Jesus
we're having 22
seconds wow we are here talking be
friends the intellectual prop property
that I'm focused on for the rest of my
life my Sesame Street meets Pokemon
trading cards we're giving away some
nfts tonight because we had over 700
we're gonna give coner service to a lot
of you because I know a lot of you don't
even know how to buy an nft you'll get
on the call with you know Jeremy could
do it trout can do it rips can do it Tai
can do it we got a lot of white glove
service Nate don't shake your head
what they doing a little oh
Z
oh my God who won NP Sports NP Sports NP
Sports NP Sports NP Sports NP Sports NP
sports
sorry wow we missed the greatest
giveaway moment of all time literally
we're way too
Focus that is I mean this is literally
like oh dude it's huge I'll sign
Rob it's rigged It's So
Random
Rand I might take my shirt
off give give we're at
738 if we get to 800 I may get more
ridiculous than what I just did and that
really requires all of you Christoph
Fernandez and goo your shorts invic Don
Colin all of you on Facebook and YouTube
Eric booster on all of you right now get
on my Twitter
or check out the text I just sent on
2129315731 I sent a text with the info
get your asses into the app there's 735
of you shit's going crazy we're gonna be
selling pins tonight that's coming up we
have a crazy Alpha we've already told
you that vcon is going to be announced
in detail tomorrow in detail tomorrow is
that right Andy no
yeah I know don't scare me I'm drinking
wine I'm
losing you're good we're gonna announce
Von tomorrow the
date right is the I'm telling you I've
been trying to tell you about the sice
of some people might not know what Von
is Von is a super conference it's the
coolest business conference in the world
Google Von we [__] crushed
Indianapolis and Minnesota in the last
two years it is remarkable it is on its
way to being one of the great
conferences in society and year three is
upon us in 2024 details coming out
tomorrow location and date we also have
another monster Alpha tonight stick
around I'm telling you it's gonna get
serious we got the eida shirt we got
Tyler we got wine let's do the next pack
do it let's actually show people let's
actually talk about this a lot of people
are joining right now they're like what
the [__] is going on and how do I get
involved tonight's episode we sold a
couple slots for Beat the Boss but in
general we do streams here live from
Hudson yards New York City at The vayer
X and the vriends HQ and we break here
we break here Yep this is rips he's here
for Youth and knowledge we call him YK
this is KH charm operations and charm OC
Misha Bend I'm here for Charisma and
looks power capability and many other
letters we're opening up packs yes
people can buy packs in our upcoming
streams next week yes how to do that
we're sold out for tonight we have fun
stuff coming up for next week's streams
top right corner V friends make sure
follow what they're seeing go back to
what they're seeing you're seeing this
right they're watching right now so they
go to top right and they click this
little thing right here right pal out
they gotta press follow have to good
next smash press the little circle V
friend circle now you see our break
schedule yes so we got tomorrow the
tomorrow's break sold out Monday and
Thursday have a lot of slots tomorrow
sold out already yeah yeah that was
already happened before we even went
live got it you got to get your [__]
notifications on if you don't have your
notific if you're turning off your
notifications if you're turning off the
noo you're making a problem Tyler no
yeah I agree yeah can't put them in the
schedule they need to hit when they hit
is Tyler wearing a wedding ring on the
opposite hand no it's old ring yeah but
it's on your what is what's that
statement
is that the new trend SLE trackers or
skill stamina all right let's walk
through this if you're on our tomorrow
if you're on our schedule you can press
Monday or Thursday stream how many what
do we got so on Monday when I click that
you press when you're there you press
the little marketpl icon it says two
braks available getting too many texts
well yeah because there's a lot of slots
just do your [__] do not disturb
great idea come on you [__] 17 spots
left for two pack bundles $ and then we
have even more of those cuz we want
wanted to get more up in the queue we
have $50 for two packs we have like 70
those available right now you're going
to get notified even if you you don't
even have to watch the whole stream
you're gonna get notified when we start
your break and then you'll of course get
it shipped to you but those that's for
Monday and then on
Thursday even maybe even more exciting
we have a couple new formats listed too
I think they're sold out but we're gonna
be testing some new things Thursday is
where people can buy into the random
breaks 10 boxes where you get a random
letter A to Z or a break where you get
um random numbers so it's two formats
like how you can get random teams in
football baseball basketball people
can't click why maybe they're not in the
app maybe they're on the desktop yeah
Pro maybe if you're on the desktop you
can't click huh if you're in the app
some people are saying mine worked so I
don't know you might have to update your
shipping info in your um I'm calling
Reuben but we have four spots and 11
spots left these are 10 box breaks 125
bucks you get get either a random letter
or number the same way people get random
teams and divisions then everything else
is just personal packs the same way
we're doing it tonight Michael Ruben on
call not even
FaceTime can we Face face shipping
info you need shipping info
Ando got it I'm live in your account
before you can buy I'm live on oh okay
grab that car Gary hasn't seen it yet I
got something big Gary to tell you y we
got it with our kit today
good got it with the kit I'll let you
reveal it 11 of 17 of
50 this is amazing rookie card inaugural
we're in the inaugural class on Fanatics
that's what we're called here got it so
that's an exclusive look how serious he
looks I love it all right all right
let's funny and beat the boss to hit
relax we got plenty of time I'm not
leaving until at least 3:00 am okay here
we go I'm gonna I don't think I don't
think people
understand sort I don't think people
understand oh look at this look at this
SI of duck just sold seven bucks yep all
right I don't think people understand
what's actually happening in V's
cardland look at this I just want
everybody see what's going on live big
Auto look at that live right now on the
duck is moving yeah I just want to get
get little B I don't like how play the
week turn your brightness down on your
phone oh that might be interesting good
call and do not Ser is also really cool
if you didn't know about it of course I
know about it duck selling I got it I'm
feeling pretty good look at this look at
this somebody just went off the board at
a thousand tough to beat a dirt a worm
from the dirt Auto one of1 just sold for
$ thousand doll that's fine look look at
us someone said I'd pay less gratitude
gorilla PSA
940 right like Po Bas yeah like I don't
think people actually who are just
joining us realize what's going on go to
V friends on eBay there's a lot going on
here look at his skilled skeleton core
30 bucks 25 on the skill category so
it's strong in the game it's strong in
our game which is TCG kind of like
Pokemon you know Magic the Gathering
Yu-Gi-Oh but also the skilled skeleton
has a collaboration with Skeletor so
that's going
on super stickers are a whole animal in
themselves pins animals in themselves
look at this look at these two super
stickers $221 for two super stickers
people bought rebok and got these for
free like I don't think people
understand people are sleeping a lot of
people in my Gary be entrepreneurial
Community have no idea what's going on
in this Fe friends these are the early
days in six years nine years 12 years
from now
Andy well remember when you and I
started making content and we had
reminisced on that flight to La the
other day and we're like joking about
like when I had 40,000 followers on
[__] Instagram people don't
understand what the [__] is happening
here with vbrs Andy they're confused
[__] are confused ABY confused
stop being confused decisive duck is not
confused decisive duck is decisive and
has made a decision knowing know him is
not confused he's confused individual no
no he's incredibly not
confused Focus Falcon rookie card look
at this that's a buck 55 in the face
that's a buck 55 in the face all right
so anyway get the [__] understanding
all right all 720 of you understand what
the [__] is going
on sorry if you're watching the kid all
right here we let's go I J rob right Rob
no no no ryro sorry rro ryro Vince
Carter nine R quick fingers ryro feels
like a Snoopy a Sno uh Scooby-Doo uh fan
ryro right by the way I'm are we picking
up enough Scooby-Doo rookie cards hard
very hard to find beat the boss I'm
focused FAL character rookie cards I own
more Buzz Lightyear rookie cards trout
then you have pairs of [__] underwear
you understand have two pairs you're
weird here we go Beat the Boss highest
score in the pack wins the Vince Carter
I'm not giving on my Vince Carter do you
understand you kids don't understand how
[__] gangster this dude was came into
the league and [__] dunked on y'all I
hated him because I'm a Nicks fan [__]
the Raptors [__]
Tonto here we go unintentional flip 66
good way to start 5 God damn it bubbly
Buzzard hit a foil by the way bubbly
Buzzard looks all [__] up yeah look at
him it's it look like
and antibubble he needs to talk to the
do about
actually he looks like he's drank a lot
of bubbly he's like a trout he's like an
old trout too much champagne all right
here we
go go one way or the other cut oh 60 66
is the ti I'm TI Ty goes to the winner
that's not good time's not good for you
fair enough respect I jumped the gun but
I know I'm going to beat you in your
mouth right now here comes a foil in
your
mouth oh no that's slow jump in the gun
big time I need to go 66 or higher 67
Higher by the way I love this [__]
character hustling
hamster I feel like hustling is finally
not full not fully canceled it's coming
back thank God I love that word can you
beat here we go can you beat
it
I'm
back New York City says stop yelling
that is the most ironic thing of all out
of all the people in the chat that could
have said stop yelling the fact that New
York C I understand if the handle was
like I but the fact that New York City
just told me to stop yelling is [__]
insane to me watch how hard I'm gonna
yell after I beat this [__] [__]
66 oh [__] I Rob takes everything ryro
ryro ryro I got that confused ryro takes
everything including the Carter let's go
ryro and eight cards good dub great
dub oh big one up
next and it's
scoob
scoob feel like the faster we get
through this the more fun we can have so
we got a
Luca PSA 10 wow that is M it's gonna be
scoo this is a big card maybe Gary Gary
might play I got both
packs that actually is insane though
imagine imagine he wins this for sco
scoop let's clap it over scoop this is a
great card this Luka Rook he knows ball
he snatched on the L saw it and he was
like
wow I B I desperately don't want to lose
this the Vince Carter I was okay with
I'm still upset about it but I've gotta
move on Show Must Go On so we're two and
two right now just are you just choosing
people at random or
already we popped it up on the screen if
you want to buy spots for our future
next week top right corner click the
logo and then there's a whole to-do I
don't know here we go press our schedule
press the market here we
go oh rough start rough start we pulled
a tidy troll 101 last stream that was
awesome oh 78 on the foil where are your
foils he's gonna need a foil 62 creative
crab bumps to a 78 I don't want to lose
this Luka you [__] dick big one for
scoo godamn it big one for scoo I'm not
going to get higher than that I need a
[__] I'm not gonna get higher 50 I
need a foil so
badou not a [__] foil I'm dead [__]
you Monday
mole my last card sco last card is a 60
G you got to beat a
78 69
and out theie I lost my l oh my God
I do not want to lose my Luca rookie
card God [__] damn it why did I let
you guys convince me to this [__] he
paid 60 bucks for that [__] yeah and and
the rare is probably like he got the
[__] luuka rookie [__] destroyed
my [__] mouth you might have another
Luca I lost a Luca rookie which is like
200 like 250 I lost a gritty ghost
Rookie Card wait Luka rookie 250 just
got smoked yeah
oh wait for the next one wait for the
next one wait for the next one it can
get bad it can get bad Durant PSA 10 it
could get bad in here it could it could
Durant PSA 10 rookie
card God if I lose this Kevin Durant
who's is this I J rob smashed it
what IJ rob a lot of suns going on J rob
I yeah J rob I like him a lot actually
this makes me happy if I lose
on the record IG Rob is such a like
actual OG of this community um I agree
once I started yelling see now New York
said see once I started [__] stop
yelling I lost I'm not losing this one
I'm keeping my Kevin Durant rookie let's
see here we go first card oh rookie card
tranquil toad rookie card tranquil toad
looks like he [__] pops tranquil no
he's [__] smoking we he's a great
character look at him [__] pop smokes
blunts to the [__] face
yeah look at him he just smoked a big
[__] fatty Philly wrapped [__]
blunt to the mouth on some dirty dirty
skunk
weed next
card the dirt what do you think you're
talking
to oh 59 Gary's toad is still in the
still in the
lead next
card toad is still only need 63 oh 67
wow big one that's a huge one that's not
that's very beatable very beatable so
I'm getting a
foil where are your foils yeah I mean I
shuffled him so they could be at the
end one more card each this I have a
weird feeling about this one I'm not 67
in the lead for the Durant PSA 10 rookie
card in the sonics Jersey wow I did that
again accidental flip but a 67 here he
needs to beat a 67 here this is n see
when Ricky Smith 04 0521 says by by
Durant that hurts my feelings I don't
want to give up this [__] Durant W
what a c conviction and confidence is
gonna beat Gary no it's not 70 is gonna
get me
there 64 God congrats to J these arej
Rob last time last time we gave away
vriends cards now we're giving away
legit legit sports cards IJ Rob beat the
boss on the Durant rips you're going to
get fired you and this [__] [__]
let's give away sports cards that work
money for $60 something getting my [__]
next get my face Beed sh oh this is a
big lock getting my [__] getting
punched in the [__]
mouth [__] this one's worse you're not
gonna like this one stay gilis Alexander
two cgc 10s it's a couple hundred bucks
easy
[__] for Rich for Rich all right Rich
let's keep the show going I'm on some
flight from Utah innocent I'm working I
blew you last night Andy I'm just
working R is like hey you want to do
some sports cars I'm like okay but I
realize you were going to [__] Rak my
collection my [__] this [__]
[__] rips oh you're gonna win this
one it's okay [__]
you these are big cards these are
beautiful cgt 10 but I know Gary's gonna
I thought I knew you were going to win
this last glass standing you're not
[__]
kidding
[Music]
legit llama to start off 67 One Last
Time can it win again you [__]
kidding me can it Win Again by the way
if you're watching right now go to
bends. cards all of you need to start
collecting these
s imagine if Pokemon was doing this
years ago and we would look back at
these videos and be like what the [__]
were we thinking right like I'm on a
50-year mission to build this
intellectual property I think there's
confusion in the
system and I like that confusion
anyway [__] you need a foil that yeah 55
skunk 67 score to
beat I'm going
1980s I'm going
1980 High School [__] I'm gonna beat
the [__] out of you in a minute
you're [__] here's your foil here's your
foil
another 50 wor score double wor score I
thought you were good at this
game all right 67 score to beat you can
still do it I'll do my last one 54 all
you need is a 50 all you need to beat is
a 67 maybe you're just who am I up
against this is rich rich he might have
another spot guys I'm telling you right
now I'm gonna beat the 67 right now I'm
gonna beat it I'm convinced for two
shades cgc 10 rookie this this was
Zander's remark my son remarkable call
we collected the [__] out of this dude
before anybody gave a [__] it's Xander's
best call I think these might be
Xander's cards I think I'm losing my
son's car I don't think these are mine
you dick face what the [__] you got have
a higher score just keep them I'll put
them on your side you're good oh my God
rip it please 68 GNA be an astronaut
watch this call an astronaut 69 69 69
I'm so invested in
this oh my
God I just want
50 is the lowest score I just P three
[__] I'm
[__] that's coldest pack I've ever
seen for that's the worst [__] pack
I've ever seen you open 40 I've seen
400,000 packs of this [__] I just
[__] lost my son's
card on to the next one that was rich
can we do can we switch up big big h two
for the urban PSA 10 Michael Irving PSA
10 rookie the hot boys we got to roll
through this we have a lot to do we got
we got Alpha to come PSA 10 Michael
Irving big Hig please follow the account
get your credit card in create your
accounts some [__] going down later that
you're gonna want all right I don't even
want to win this which means I'm G win I
don't want to win don't even want to win
I don't want Michael urvan he doesn't
give the Jets love he's a cowboy screw
the Cowboys let's roll let's go fast 50
garbage I'm winning so far 55 I'm
winning winning 66 this is the way to do
it 50 oh let's get a third 58 takes big
get four cards Gary keeps to Michael Irv
that was kind of tough but you guess
what Happ did not beat the boss Steve
Nash PSA 10 Steve Nash PSA 10 Steve Nash
the man double zeros Steve Nash PSA 10
can you beat the ball giveaway relax
everyone in here get it to 800 all of
you if you would share the link and
everybody who's watching these other
platforms get on n Suns get on ftic live
there's a lot of suns a lot of sun stun
Suns if I pull stun sun right here just
wait 60 Gary got the crocodile beat look
how cool this is you're gonna die fly
tell me you don't want this [__] card
tell me you don't want this card get on
eBay right now and find this this is the
[__] [__] best card you're gonna
die
fly can you beat can I beat a 63 59 oh
78 the
first I can still might beat was this is
the man man man for the Nash 10 can I
beat it
61 I gotta beat a 78 nope NOP not happen
and a panther rookie the man he gets his
four cards Gary keeps the N you did not
beat the ball the man is not beating the
ball Rich again Barry Sanders PSA 10 by
way every time every time we like sit
and dwell I lose when we go fast like
this where I don't give a [__] I'm
winning Rich can you beat the ball how
did Rich SN got he must have had the
quickest Rich got in twice did he beat
me last time um no he just lost just now
lose twice in a row sand 10 boom Oh big
card 69 zombies hard to find [__]
Halloween stay
tuned [__] oh 71 the mo is one of the
cool Here Comes insert insert insert
insert 62 [__] insert it's got to be a
monster here f and a 70 what a pack for
be the boss 69
7071 Barry Sanders PSA 10 and all eight
cards going home Community the community
is clean these are pretty much giveaways
my friends whether they whether Gary Lon
or not [__] I just get lost bar Sanders
rookie I didn't even want the Steve Nash
rookie I love Steve would have liked to
so we have a Dion 10 coming up for
Adrien guys I'm getting my oh no this is
big [__] if I lose this Deon rookie
prime time Dion PSA 10 coach you can't
go home for Adrian against Adrian this
is a big one PSA 10 rookie card can you
beat the boss Adrien I don't think you
can you throw some foils left I'm gonna
win this you can't lose this one 61 I'm
losing
54 I'm
losing be a big core coming here 63 okay
this has to be a
foil my gosh and 55 polish poodle the
score to beat is a 64 63 so we need a 64
higher a prime tops traded PSA 10 rookie
card in the height of Coach Prime the
timing could not be worse kind of like
the Jets playing the [__] Chiefs this
Sunday night on football and Sunday
Night
Football
[__] oh it's a bad box for this is not
how we anticipated this going on 10 get
me more wine this is the
worst aquabumps last pack this is big
this is big I hate this this is the
worst this is the worst because you're
gonna lose your [__] job Theon nine
Sanders nine and Aman nine three big
rookie PSA 9es and beat the boss fourth
edition aquab I did so well on Beat the
ball that's why it was like up in the
got my ass kick tonight yeah aquab boms
last pack of Beat the Boss then we can
say goodbye to all
this you're going to win this you have
to have a foil in here have to all right
we're at 7-Eleven I feel a lot of people
are not doing their job while they're
watching now I know you're being
entertained you're thrilled with my
misery I know how humans work but we
need to share this link and get this to
800 because at 800 I'm gonna give away
banana [__] and I mean bananas [__] I
mean like taking Three Bananas taking a
poop on it and giving it two
all right here we go big one three NES
you still like me let's go I hate you
all right you need a foil here oh Ty at
59 Ty goes to the B for everybody who
doesn't know about V friends this is the
character you need to get into
headstrong honey badger headstrong we're
good headstrong honey badger this is a
[__] how cool is this card and being
headstrong you could see it like could
be bad you're like stubborn but I see it
as like conviction I think Headstrong
Honeybadger and conviction
cockroach have some great adventures in
their future one of the great Sports
warm-up songs of
all next card for three legendary PSA 9
you know that oh no feels fairy 67 you
can beat that you [__] don't touch
me 57 you have a foil here your foil my
card this has to be like a spec or
something
61 if this is not a [__] foil beat 67
you only have one foil so I'm [__]
I'm tearing this full Studio [__]
round
92 wow
92 these are going
nowhere put and my last card you still
get your four 54 but Gary wins the last
round to beat the boss you still get the
fairy Rookie Card wait this sh shark is
a beast that's a beast would have been
fitting for aquabumps too but nope now
we have a Clean Slate to do whatever we
want I'm so glad beat the boss is over
that was bad where's my wine that was
the beat
down all
right that briefcase to We Gotta Give
let's do giveaways we gotta do giveaways
uh oh what is this what the [__] is this
say with me what the [__] is this on
three one two three what the [__] is
this we'll tell you later all right here
we go we can give Clean Slate okay clean
SL
we got we got these pin we haven't sold
those yet we haven't sold how many pins
do we have five let me see them we have
them y all right those are the four
thank you we're we've got five pins we
got five we got five pins should we sell
these I think we should right yeah I
think there's there might
wow guys she trying to end Myer try what
the [__] is this if I drink this I might
give away the whole
company tomorrow there might be a press
release like presswire Donnie pants 49
of
God uh winx.com can everybody all 714 of
you type in winx.com so that people sign
up something that people should support
my dad's thing best way to if you buy
wine on the internet on like dumb [__]
like wine.com you need to sign up for
winx.com um all right let's put up these
five slots what's the hardest one to
rare robot oh God somebody pulled a rare
robot all right we're going to put these
up for sale maybe a giveaway before yeah
but let's put them up for sale and set
that up we only got five packs to give
away how much are we doing them at and
what whatever you said tell us to right
oh no we have him at 40 can we set the
price we can set the
price oh yes sir whatever you want to do
let's do
407 47 I'm in a weird mood 47 bucks I'm
GNA auction these off right now now and
we're going to put him back in the box
and you know what I'm going to do to
make the value even better nice
one
two just to give
people all right we'll see who's fastest
on the trigger to buy these signed boxes
of Mystery Collection
pins only five we're GNA open them up on
the spot here we
go
go they up who fast fingers of rich is
going to get one for sure rich is going
to get all
five gone yeah Jesus they move fast I'm
very confused they were gone like double
the time before we said they were gone
they they gone they're gone okay let's
rip them fast fast let's rip him should
we start a I'm very confused how this
all works you want to do a giveaway and
then
rip I'll show you next time no it's not
Bots it's not bot there's no bots on
here the payment's automatically set up
all you have to do is press the button
right everyone's credit cards ready in
it right text yeah yeah all right should
we open these but first we should do a
giveaway we got Sports here everything
else here what do we got here all SPS
let's do oh let's see how people react
you like this little pristine 10 of the
awesome African
civit or no not that I'm not that I just
did that to show off Halloween Vibe
Etc this is a monster an 8.5 rare by the
way look at this who's it yeah what
people don't know is these people don't
understand is these are more valuable
than the others because look at that t
you see what's going on there yeah do
yeah people don't
understand now there's also there some
weird stuff
also there's also Paul I think people
really like this man little Chris Paul
rookie
card Chris Paul he said Warrior now he
doesn't like Chris Paul do he like Chris
yeah he lost the finals to the buck I
remember I mean you guys know what I
think about this guy this [__] beast
is that uh
vay vayer Sports his own bo bo
bashet do a
combo see people are asking about hockey
cards card well that card I absolutely
love that card all you know what I feel
like there's a lot of entrepreneurs here
so why don't
we
theic live can you draw an l SP want to
see your lad I probably misspelled
it who knows little something little
misspell error card we're doing away
this right now we're giving away an
entrepreneur elf cgc 9 core card right
now here we go got a doodle got a little
Dole doodle the hat is live is live gets
here we go you spelled hypnosis right
the other day that was awesome that was
insane what does it say Vita's
lie is
Live's live oh my God I'm honestly I'm
still on tilt from getting my [__]
face annihilated on Beat the Boss how
can people buy slots for upcoming events
we'll give this away we're gonna open
these five pins right now so much Alpha
to get to we should do that after the
pins yeah I think we give this away
right now'll be quick it should be quick
fa's
live more wine people are trying to get
me out of
here
you know like look I got $655 very yeah
scuba weex is crazy I don't think people
understand what wich.com people about
that
quarterback that's right every time
there's two seconds left we throw up to
two and give a big shout out to Zack
Wilson number two on New York death
might be our only chance out your
[__] mouth when Zack Wilson throws
four touchdowns in Patrick M's mouth
this Sunday Night Live in Taylor [__]
Swift's [__] [__] face on national TV
all of you going to shut your [__]
mouth we forgot who won we always forget
that part this is
really sure damn it we gotta go see who
won Chad who won it's always from me who
won gone chiefs no no who
won it's a big string of letters
probably
[__] it was a big string of
letters I'm so confused who won we'll
have it in no no seriously who won
it was a long name service random letter
someone someone signed up RMG Services
contr F can you guys please look at
Hanan y we forget about that part it's
no
good it's it was RBG
Services RMG RMG Services let's go
RMG that's a big win that's a big one
that's a nice one I need some feedback
real time feedback how are we enjoying
the stream why don't you set up the five
packs let's get to going how everybody I
want I want to talk oh we're under 700
now people it's getting a little later
it's 1019 we slowed down the pace and I
feel bad because we're gonna give away
crazy [__] everybody in this shck Daniel
Rick Victorious Lucy great to see you um
please get over to the app um people are
enjoying yeah people want to win some
[__] we're ready to go all right let's
open it up first one for Zen rosta
here's what we're looking at Guys these
are the first ever vriends pins released
at vcon in Indianapolis Indiana We're
looking there's all types of
Rarities the rare robot is the hardest
one to find this the one you want other
popular ones the they're all popular
Angel harpic the leopard's hard the
turkey if we pull a rare robot tonight
I'm running into my office pulling
something crazy again like the Deadpool
first appearance comic and gonna give it
away for free so everyone should put in
the chat rare robot rare robot Andy pull
up the rare robot song get it over here
for me play it on Loop get me going
Jeremy if you're faster than Andy
that'll be fine because I need the
action I need the action
let's open this all right this first one
is Zen
Rasta get over here with that Zen rosta
get over here there's two little black
bags in each spot start from the
top go back put it right here get it
right here I don't think people
understand this song Oh dial and dog
fresh nice dial and dog let's clap it up
for the dial and dog
pick hold here we go start from the top
here we go I don't think people
understand oh
no no way oh my God no way no
way on Gary for like a year since
Von I cannot believe it rare robot pin
I'm stunned what you have you said
you're going to do something I'm going
to go oh my
gosh R
robot
wow are you [__] who got that Zen Ros
Zen R and the sign box holy [__] that
was an epic
moment but this is like extremely the
thing that's different about pins and
it's cards too there's so many cards out
there there's not as many pins out there
and people really hardcore collect the
pins so there's not like flippers like
grading and selling it's a very hardcore
collector
crew wow is then R in the chat I also I
also can drop it and not have to worry
about like a like a cgc eight Happening
Here you drop it I mean I can like like
there's
no I don't I don't want to drop
it this is the
robot how many rare robots are there you
I can't even find them on eBay because
he was part of this three pack this one
went for like 400
like lower than 480 but like real money
this is a [__] expensive P just to
give you context everyone who's new 485
this is a rare robot sticker look at the
prices on these rare robot stickers six
and
change yeah 700 I mean it's wow that's a
huge pin all right and the music was
playing that was do okay we'll keep
going so everybody knows I did say just
earlier if we pulled the rare robot I
was going to go into my office and pull
some very expensive and valuable and I'm
going on that Journey better John Carney
you're up next sign box heading your way
in the two pins inside by the way just
so everybody knows everyone just won
that rare robot means Phil you going
home the whole chat right I'm St at 3:
a.m. um I'm gonna go get something
everyone just won because now everyone's
GNA be eligible for something free from
my office insane John Carney these are
for you let's see what we get oh the
happy hermit crab happy hermit crab and
next up good night oh positive
porkie nice
pin nice pins porcupine and hermit crab
for John Carney next up Raider nauy
naughty was in the chat early saw
naughty in there when you pop these open
guys it's a little sticker it says void
so you know it's already been opened
can't get away from that we have a lot
of alpha coming I know some defense
folks are probably waiting that's what's
the brief that's what the briefcase is
we might get to it in the next few days
hours we might get to it by 4 a all
right so this was for greater naughty I
cannot believe we pulled the robot that
is so hard to do oh the Dapper dashound
little long pin Dapper dashound and
no you're
kiding
are you [__] kidding me never never
that how I know it's hard to get
duplicates of anything never mind the
robot this is I've never seen that in my
whole life my whole life there's no pin
case with two robots in it this was on
yourself for like eight months you could
have opened these are you [__]
kidding
me that's
it
oh my God cat Bing they don't even know
like how big of a deal that is because
it's p and not
C oh my
God you guys it's not work red
red we we only need one of them
playing we have two I don't like
it I've never seen two s if you're a v
friends fan you know this is like
massive I've never seen that ever that
is epic that was had good career of
beer I I wish you a lot of luck on your
next
Endeavor I feel like we Le a lot
together what is
happening but
uh what did I do wrong in this
scenario you're put in the firing me
oh there's been some what you [__]
destroyed me where did that come from
all right what you ready sleepover no
no if you here's the first here's the
first all right if you
watched the blanket if you watch the
latest we're doing huge giveaway here
the blanket I'm three don't be dick I'll
beat your face this is huge GPS anybody
who watched V friends I mean excuse me
trash this episode saw that the $100
Yankee [__] the Yankee [__] this
is the Yankee blanket this retro Yankees
blanket is like a$2 200 [__] dollar
[__] ety [__] monster all right so
we're giving it away we got we got to
find a big box here we go let's give
away the Y
it followers only baby followers only
you [__] are watch trash no
dude it was a huge you should have seen
this [__] moment in trash talk I
think her name was Linda or something
she was [__] amazing we negotiated
and it was [__] amazing and you have
understand in the context of trash you
understand how big trash talk is people
give a [__] yeah Trash Talk matters all
right only giveaway I'm not entering for
yikes who said that
b roll it back roll it back just said
only we won't be a there I want to see
it I want them done it go so fast ban
them they're finished that's it ban for
Life ban for life you can't go that fast
yane blank wait wait wait no it's old it
goes too
fast one I'm not entering Dad Dad Bob a
customer a loyal customer I gotta take a
note write down dad Bob dad Bob see you
wait maybe he wasn't entering out of
generosity Zack w someone won we didn't
even do Zack Wills dad Bob [__] me up
Dad Bob you're on record he also just
said Boston
mfer w w i i
w
[Laughter]
w two robots here you go also I can't
believe two robots are you
[__] all right the next thing that
we're giving away because there was two
robots is the first astronaut squish
mellow that I'm gonna sign we gave one
away previously I
know pretty sick I think I do well there
look at this [__] Crush
gra all right
The Adventurous astronaut squish mellow
Auto we're giving away right now let's
do
it and we're setting up for a big I'm
gonna rip the next two while we're while
the giveaway on if you pull another rare
robot I'm going to lose my [__] this
one is for Sam K or Sam e not sure Sam m
e k there can't be another there can't
be another Rob
s
s followers only it's live here we go we
can't miss Z and then we can I get the
uh let me these two and this thank you
sir Sam K come on Sam K I cannot believe
you P two thought was last was possible
I didn't know that's possible to do o
Nifty narwhal nice one that's my second
favorite actually Nifty Nar
nice nice gold oh ambiti angel with a
little glitter on that that is for same
k
samc s Sam now one more for e c our last
pin box well there was two for one
person no no no okay
Sam a lot of people want this squish
mellow for their daughter I'm gonna
finish this one up in the next 20
seconds I'm telling you the pins are so
and we got the Olympics coming up
ComicCon pin culture collectible
pins we got eight seconds here oh the
heart pick oh God what [__] what a
creature I'm like freaking out Z
wi wow we were on that this is the if
someone open this like for them this is
the best thing ever all right who's
gonna win this let's see the last pin is
Happy hermit crab way to finish it off
good stuff harp pick's a rare one wait
the boxes had two pins yes Diner C Diner
52 52 92 yeah two din two pins in a
box2 big
win let's go back to blank Sate Fe Diner
we have some Alpha okay be a good time
this is it yeah this is the time all
right everybody one more time because
we're we're transitioning now in the
show a serious
time how many people in the chat I'm
glad that we're over 700 this important
time we're heading into you know we're
an hour and a half in three or four
glasses in bunch of free ship that we've
given away in lot of time the OG's Phil
trout right Nate people that used to
have the passion they're
gone Tyler you and Andy as OG's are here
clearly Rising above the competition the
youngsters are here the next gen is here
lot of next genen is
here and we're about to
drop
let's remember what do we say when we
see this on three one two three what the
what is in the
Box what [__]
dude complely ruined the show that a box
it's a [__] is way to switch off of
the
hand have to say hand can yeah keep the
hand
cam what the [__] is that here we go on
three because you were off key and then
this guy set a box one more time on
three one two three what the [__] is
that there we go I think we're gonna
tell people we're out the time it's like
pul fiction up in this [__]
right Alpha season
oh oh there a box a box wow the only way
to do it wow
this transition right here got a box
here you can get rid of that I'm very
excited we're dropping the massive this
has never been open before massive Alpha
for everybody oh hand cam is just in a
bad spot maybe we zoom in up here I
can't believe I can't believe I gave
away that Yankees blanket that is
[__] perfect you put that on [__]
Etsy or [__] marari Yankee blanket
yeah bro that Yankee blanket is a 200a
it's a 200
it's
I do the honor here my I can hold on let
me do a little POV who this show the
color what's
Happ never before seen I've never seen
it you never seen any all right let me
tell you what's happening here we are
dropping massive Alpha here this so
strange stop being
weird
but the hand cam doesn't work compound
the hand cam does look this is a very
big deal holy [__] oh we got to see the
badge I need the hand cam action I just
need to make it
work look at that logo at the
Logo put it down it down
okay we are unveiling for the first time
ever the Halloween
collection which are incredibly
interesting because rips you're the OG
here you and I have architected this
please explain to this is huge for the
real vriends people I know a lot of
people here don't know what's happening
but a lot of people are about to get
very excited here this is a massive
Alpha announcement Jolly Jacko the face
of the bren's Halloween there's a lot
going on a lot of Ip going on please
tell everybody what we're looking at
here I don't even know how to start man
this is the vriends Halloween Mystery
Collection this first collection since
vcon there's 15 characters they're all
Halloween
focused see them all let's talk about
you want to do everyone bold as [__] bat
yeah competitive clown Fearless fairy
gritty ghost Jolly Jacko motivated
monster notorious ninja oh the resilient
red devil off the bat very hard to find
skill skeleton hard to find the devil oh
yeah yeah Devil's the chase it's like
the robot of this
generation what else we got here smooth
spider trusting tarantula vibing vampire
well-connected werewolf zealous zombie
those are your core pins so core pins
are kind of all we had in the vcon set
there's no like Chasers variance so we
have Rarity within all of these it'll
show it on the box we'll get there we
have the new Spooktacular these are like
spectaculars the V the V friends one of
ones these are not one of one pins
they're very limited edition it's a one
per case hit on average it says down
here one per case on
average and then and then we have two
additional Chasers the glow-in-the-dark
ghost additional Chaser and little
something there that people might have
seen at the vcon Museum they might have
got a little Alpha it's been on the
shirt tonight
little hit on the shirt huh it's a black
cat pin first ever black cat pin series
one made with
587 sapphires black rodium and 18 karat
gold so that's a bigger Chaser there's
more to come on this there only you want
to say I do there's only one in the
whole entire set because there's there's
40 total those are going to be released
at a future date 39 in a future date
only one in the boxes so this is a box
God hope it's not in this that would be
so [__] up I would kill
someone when I say someone I mean
you we're opening so real quick this is
a box so it's gonna pop out real nice so
we got a we got seals on the gotta slice
the seals
on pin in the original so just so you
know new character just so everybody
understands I got it I got it I got it
there's pins
and oh I geez we forgot that
we no this open one let's open one okay
wait I want to pop this out real pretty
it's nice are you GNA show it like a
retailer oh it gets pretty I know I know
how to do retail look at this you see
this I work at Wine Library my whole
life I know how to pop it [__] collar
look at this I I'll continue to try to
hold this look at this look at this
there they are now now these are going
to be
at the ComicCon they're launching
they're going to be available online
soon and there's going going to be and
here's a big outut these are going to be
heavily
discounted heavily discounted this the
first time we're seen them I've seen
samples not actual is
it holy [__] wait should we give it away
should we sell some should we I'm not
[__] giving these away you [__]
Maniac all right let's play Beat the
Boss
[Laughter]
no look at the pumpkins in the
background like metallic shimmery on
that box
look I think we just launched the alpha
that nobody has we have not announced
actually what's happening here and this
is about to get so crazy no no no let's
just open one let's open one let's show
the back like let's get a Vibe for this
for the box so on the back it actually
tells you the percentage chance of
finding the characters that's new which
I think is really fun oh interesting
since I can't see anymore because I'm
old break it down it goes anywhere from
10% is the highest from the Jacko and
the monster those are fresh pins down to
2% at the lowest with the the Red Devil
um so that means when you open a box so
we want chance right so these will be
available for sale so cool ComicCon
these are so cool for sale at ComiCon
and
online ComicCon live at the Javit Center
not far from here
soon but they got seals on them from the
V look I want I want to do something
crazy here we're gonna sell these
tonight these gonna be the first people
to get them wow all 10 all 10 but what I
want to do is because we're gonna Avail
it tonight wow we're just alfing the
[__] out of tonight it's a special night
what I want to tell everybody though
is we're gonna sell these for tonight
because I'm going to sign them for 60
bucks all
right they're gonna be 50 at comc con 50
MSRP yeah right they're gonna be 50 on
the website except and this is about to
get the OG hardcore people at vriends
there is an advantage in price for V
friends nft holders yes why don't to
explain that it's pretty simple there's
a couple waves we're going to be
announcing them late this week I believe
Friday which we're kind of announcing
right now we're announcing it now that's
also true in detail everything about the
set will be announced later on The Price
is a $50 MSRP yeah by the way $50 I mean
it's we've already unveiled it so so
you're getting a pin and stick with me
here everybody if you haven't been
following a super sticker if you know
anything about what's going on in super
stickers and V friends this is a
humongous deal you get a pin and a super
sticker for 50 [__] dollars they're
also they're also way yeah see they're
they're also way this is T in her own
horn here they're way better than what
we did at Von Von's Edition zero they're
GNA have a special place in history
these are I want to say 20% bigger the
pins I love this so everybody already
knows that's a good price but wait till
everybody hears what happens if you
currently own of be
nft I'm going to continue toting real
quick pins are bigger super stickers are
better theyve printing on the back we'll
get to it they're higher much higher
quality there's different Chasers
there's the blackout gems there's
glow-in-the-dark pins there's a lot of
variants the discount if you hold a
vriends nft there's a couple stick with
me here I'm excited about this this is
no [__] $50 a box we're about to
sell the first boxes at 60 because I'm
GNA sign them right here right now 10
boxes going off the board you ready I
have five ready to go do I'm going to do
another yeah I can do if I can do five
and then I'll do another listing with
with five people because I have it
formatted so it's like set for five okay
because we only did it for the mystery
pin so we thought we were only going to
do five for we'll do two rounds we do
five it's up to you we could do we'll do
five to start five to start five to
start to start five to start um should
we tell them the discount there's going
to be a couple ways so real quick a lot
of Hardcore befriends people in here
need to pay attention tonight is six I'm
going to sign the
boxes but if you want a be friend nft
these will be available on our website
when um we only locked in the tensa on
tens no no we don't need to St next
month early next month early next month
early October when is when is uh
ComicCon 102 got it so October 12th here
at the Java Center right here people are
going to be there but if they're $50 at
the at ComicCon they're $50 on our
website
unless you own a vends
nft it's going to be limited and we're
going to Cadence it but what is the
discount on the website if you actually
own a V nft and people are obviously
already asking series one series two
break it
down I'm Gonna Keep the nitty-gritty
details because it's still being
finalized series ones will have the
earlier shot in series two if you own a
series one you will have the ability to
buy it earlier they may sell out in that
kind of format or yeah they can sell out
on free sale very easily y so series one
is getting the biggest Advantage
correct it's $25 per box Half Price Half
Price $25 a box if you own a series one
VR again for a super sticker and a
[__] pin $25 [__] dollars if you
want a series one let's [__]
go let's go
baby how many can you buy there's a
limit there's a limit it's probably te
I'll say what we're probably gonna do
it's two cases so they come in sealed
cases there's 10 mini boxes in a case
they come in that sweet case of 10 it's
going to be two cases and then people
can also buy loose boxes so I think it's
gonna be a 10 box limit on the loose
okay but people can buy a case for
249.99 or a sealed box for $24.99 so
there's really nice entry point there
and then we have a small very small
allocation set for Fanatics live for
everyone who's watching because that'll
be really cool too that's very nice but
we have we have them ready so the way
we're going to launch it is there's
series one there's going to be
advantages there's a little bit of like
people forgot about the spooky bees yeah
from gift goat there's a little
something just a random Hall oh that's
right it wasn't even gift goat you're
right 31 of them Halloween don't even
know about the mini drops the OG's dud
Jeremy
does but they SP out like there's tears
if it doesn't make it to public sale
make it a public sale anyway we don't
we're not going to give you anymore
when's the blog post coming out
hopefully Friday okay hopefully Friday
which means mandatory Friday or you're
fired awesome it's a big Friday can we
drop right now the first five ever this
is insane we're gonna [__] I'm freaking
out excited about this exactly is people
are GNA get it in their hands it's
really cool are you ready to Lo this
should take aund of a second right yeah
so you're gonna hit enter people are
gonna cck no it's not yet he's gonna hit
I'm gonna say go
I'm gonna say
boo I'm gonna say boo instead of go I'm
gonna say boo and then you're GNA click
and then the first five are gonna be off
the board yep you'll then immediately
get the next five because people are
upset exactly they're like they need at
least next exactly and we're gonna open
these on the spot yeah I've never opened
one in my whole life it's crazy nor have
anyone correct these are the first ones
to exist we got them ear I've never
opened one in my here we go if you want
to buy one of these 60 bucks y actually
make it 66 for can you change it
yeah go
66 the sign box alone people will are
we're gonna go
ready poker Pros nft Rich we love you
back Rich we love you back Rich says we
love you friends we love you back lots
of stuff going on this is the the
ultimate Chaser it has 587 gems 570
blackes the the people that made this
said suggested retail 2000 2 000 but
that's also just in the materials it
doesn't even count like the colle IP the
collectible value there's only one
that's going to be in these boxes and
then we have 39 more and they will be
available at some point before the end
of the year we're talking through some
stuff talk stuff Black Friday Black
Friday but the Jets play the we'll
figure it out we'll figure out 600 570
black
sapphire yellow Sapp for 25 bucks and
get one of somebody's gonna get this
it's also here's some Alpha it's it's
got lucky on the back right there it's a
BR it's a pin it's a broch I think
that's how you pronounce it and it's got
a loop for a necklace or chain if you
want to wear it on your necklace so this
thing is
justers that thing this thing is just
Bonkers people gonna be chasing I hope
we pull an insert tonight one of these
surprise ghosts it's gonna be huge are
we ready is everyone
ready
chat go
if Rich gets in who's got fast fingers
it's definitely and they're gone
yeah it's definitely gone yo who got in
me BP
Bron who else who else who
else who else polish someone said polish
we didn't even see them pop up Polish
Polish got in Let's Go Polish yes should
we do the next five or should we do
these first and then the next let's do
these first we're play that music in the
background go polishes
so we got CD me BP Broncos polish Prime
Time 9
and it's List It List listed so this is
everybody thank you so much for joining
uh Jung sik Lee on Facebook great to see
you Lita how are you be friends is a
Pokemon meets Sesame Street intellectual
property in nft form in trading card
form in pin form in animation form we're
building out a a huge huge huge
intellectual property for the next five
Decades of my life we are opening up the
first there's no Bots here it's just
people clicking it as soon as it pops up
I mean we get paid we see the you gotta
hit two buttons boom boom all right so
this is the first ever box there's
safety seals on each side that say void
when we open it so don't buy them on the
secondary Market if they're not sealed
yeah we did we're we're really trying to
protect you all from repacks and things
of that nature so we gota show them that
we went to heavy I know but show them
mhm nice Security Seals we're looking
for Spooktacular I think we call it a
recessed metal it's like a almost like a
gun metal of each saying turn that music
off I apologize cliping where it shows
up in the app
right you gotta be in the store no no no
you don't no well you
don't I'll show you I'll show you when
we
do you want me to do it yes you deserve
it brother you rips worked very hard and
was the leader of this obviously I had
my be hired thanks God let's open here
we go all right the first ever box oh
you know what let me just hold on who
got this CD me c d a n mey wow Cory
right did you see look at this first
ever box first ever box you with the old
European spelling forever so you see
here we got void stickers I can't spell
for [__] these tops are fresh look that
logo let's go I SP that you can't really
see it but the and R I know you're
confused here we go here's what we're
looking at this is f it's like an abyss
I just want people to understand if you
knew what a lot of you don't know what's
going on with pins and super stickers a
$50 price on a two pack with this pin
and a super sticker is bananas the fact
that VRA so bigger it's heavier and real
quick V friends holders even series two
oh my God look at that so sick look yeah
this is what happened don't show the
front I won't just so everybody knows if
you remember at the
national there was no no back it was
blank back kind of they're really th
they're really thin too these are like
legit are you pump how cool is this this
is [__] amazing some WTF no shot so
cool whoa okay so we'll look at that I'm
gonna do the pin pin first this match
this is [__] they're going to be the
same
but this is a bigger pin I feel it this
is the first ever I'm so super
excited oh motivated monster
first p in the book which
means the match so that you can't see it
here this is the first ever super
sticker for Halloween unveiled limited
to 4.99 in the back it's got like little
bats floating we have background scenes
on like little backgrounds on these I
know we did we worked hard in this yeah
these are you can't you can only see it
in these are gonna be [__] cgc 10 all
day PSA 10 all day bgs 10 all uh 9.5 all
day that is sick again please read the
chat everybody please explain to
everyone who's new how big the super
stickers are in our world how rare a 499
is with the elevated backs now the quami
are the same on the pins heavier [__]
the pin is great way bigger bigger like
where's let's get one of the other on
who got that that's [__] let's let's
get one or
something
the Arbitrage on the pins and super
stickers have been crushing on eBay very
limited I'm super pum we don't need to
we don't need we need let's go to next
it's nice it's a very sizable difference
no it's a big difference all right next
box BP
Broncos BP Broncos dude I'm like nervous
this is
insane I'm gonna go right look what TCG
bul King said 499 of that less than how
many people are watching right now at
[__] 11m that's by the way that's the
most highest Rarity so they're all very
limited that's that's why it's like a
limited production here they're going to
move it's the highest
quantity box number two for BP Broncos
this is so cool ready G yeah I'm
ready oh the big head
boom Jolly Jacko oh the [__] mascot
this is the logo Jolly Jack the logo the
hen to let check out the stickers are in
these nice little New York City
residents you're about to get a big
Alpha on this as well coming up that's F
jesz you see the pumpkins in the back
it's so much easier to see in person but
that is so cool also the most those are
the two most common to knock it off
because they're too cool where like
people everyone's gonna be pumped to get
those because they're just that cool got
it so pumpkin and motivated monster have
the highest those are yeah those two are
both 10% high pop got it high pop CU
because could open be pumped Pumped
monsters wow I love motivated monst yeah
we s said look not going to lie these
look really amazing they really are
we're really excited about this I wish a
lot of you understood you're
pumped look they're [__] very rare
comic con ComicCon we're gonna get a ton
of new people into our ecosystem the
ones that are going to sell on the
website you got to imagine everybody who
owns an actual befriends nftd is going
to kill on that $25 Arbitrage they're
just going to sit like there's not going
to be a lot like it's all supply and
demand it's why the Brilliance of the
super sticker of the national you know
many people threw out yeah through out
the super sticker they didn't know they
had someone wrote they just sold 19 for
3,300 bucks super stickers yeah give
them for free so let's super stickers
were given for free at the national this
is this is Polish buddy so super
stickers released at the national for
the first time as a promo in the VIP
bags people are gonna be looking at
their bags in like 30 years like where
the hell was my V friends so I like to
do a little peek to see which side to
open the sticker on nice job I'm gonna
open I'm gonna open it Gary's first ever
pin bik
it pins and stickers match which is
really nice gonna be able to put
together both
sets I saw what it
was who's is this for Polish Polish
Polish I got exciting news for you sick
that sick wow that is
sick wow he's vibing the sticker If I'm
remembering right
really enter so little
rare which
means 399 so the poses that's 399 the
poses no it's not the Rarity but the
super stickers are meant to be like
competing Sports Cardy poses compared to
the pins which are like the classic
edition zero pose somebody said look
like my
ex-wife oh my god wow amazing do it
that's fresh damn polish
how dare next is prime time how dare you
talk about like that prime
time man this is so [__] exciting
thank you for joining be friends our
intellectual property Pokemon meet
Sesame Street tonight we're opening up a
very big Alpha surprise Alpha even
before a blog post which is how we
normally drop things we decided to do it
here live on Fanatics live this is big I
want to do this it's a big
one oh what is this don't be the gems
black cat please
it could be glow-in-the dark glowing it
could be glowin the- dark if it has so
they're both blue if it's like all the
same color blue it's glowing the dark if
it has dark blue eyes it's regular so
this could be a monster who's this for
this is for prime prime time prime time
if we turn this over and it's a
glow-in-the dark that's rare yeah it's
the only glow the dark it's the only
glowin the dark in the set regular but
still sweet still gorgeous still sweet I
can only imagine how sick the 101 looks
compared
like the
one that
is oh that is sick
that's that's super sweet to 449 little
Graves little oh it's little ghosts in
the backyard in the background there
little ghosts hanging out that looks
like my second
wife New York's been married a lot very
nice good hit let
go we need to get more I think we only
we sent a very low amount for Fanatics
live we should probably get more over
here as you said last one of these five
look I mean it's been a remarkable night
we have slots available for future hit
the top right corner look at our
calendar it linston it iton I don't know
exactly the right why don't I do this
I'll look don't worry um why don't you
do the next five no why don't you look
at your phone real quick and see how
many slots have been sold for future
stuff right a lot of streams coming up
oh I can't get rid of this SP we haven't
even added the these for Halloween yet
here we go
here we go come
on oh oh baby wow spider that's sick
that one's sweet wow gorgeous man nice
oh come off that's
nice look at this smooth spider someone
play Smooth Criminal for me in the
background smooth
E5 alien and
farm uh oh
rips this came out gorgeous yeah that's
too
cool
3.99 those are the five those are the
first five those are the first five wow
all of our starter decks sold out for so
that I'm looking at tomorrow's stream
we're about to go into the next five
everybody I know a lot of you want to
buy slots for future stuff rips is GNA
show you right now and
we chat can you hear music or is it too
far all right I I know a lot of you want
to get future slots rips is going to
show you right now for the 662 of you so
you can be part of us next week and get
slots and these are inexpensive like 25
50s 50s I'm gonna take I'm gonna take a
minute to show because I think we're
almost sold out so I want to make sure
people are getting it actually right so
just like I'm gonna join our stream just
like you guys are now two cases a lot
for each orderer would love that chance
S series two holders should be able to
buy right if it reaches them it has to
be it's series one first I know we
really really want to come through for
series one but guess what we have five
more packs available
tonight I'm going to go through this I
want to go through this so we'll let the
we want the next five but I've decided
that I want these to be
$89 it's just the way it is it's just
the way it is like these are very
special and I'm completely convinced
they're first night pack look it's first
night packs first off the line I'm gonna
sign them they're I'm gonna and I'm
gonna number them I'm gonna number this
one which I didn't do with the first
ones number
six number seven you want to sign them
you do it or after number eight you know
so the first ones did not get numbered
number nine cuz these are going to be
what did I just say feeling number 10
you should write boo on it it's
scary oh
boo not enough drying time in my opinion
what's your all time Halloween costume
that you've pulled off devil that's a
really good one I was a punk rocker in
sixth grade killed it Sylvia ventur my
crush said I looked good
wow all right here's how we're let's see
how much we have left for the next two
streams you guys are all here with me
here's how you get to the other streams
and breaks VF it's only it's until next
week JD crypto my my auto is not void
when we open it we put it back in the
Box the Box you still have we're gonna
ship it nicely Connor is a [__] Conor
is the con man I trust I trust him let's
go but these are gonna be $89 you got
them set up yep 89 all right let's check
out the future streams all right for
everybody right now who doesn't
understand how to buy spots for our
future fut streams coming up next week
here we go be friends on the top right
you have to be following get everybody
get over oh somebody said I'd pay $99
you know what let's up them to9
$99 good call everybody who's mad
Jorge somebody I'll P 150 I scary game9
you guys are playing scary 99 okay guys
I'm gonna do this once and for all press
top right vriends follow I have a
feeling I'm not gonna get through this
follow hit follow press the vriends icon
you get to our show schedule tomorrow's
break I think a lot of people follow
tonight right we're at 1400
y obviously you'll see tomorrow's break
is all sold out when you press our
Marketplace icon all sold out every
single break now dang it I should not
have pressed yesterday's that's a very
not a smooth UI back up going into our
schedule Monday is my pack Monday Monday
it's personal packs you can buy I think
all the starter kits sold out we sold
kits of five packs so if I go into
Monday there's still a break if you
press the breaks available there's 14
spots left out of a hundred so they've
been buying tonight yeah 14 lefts out of
a 100 for the bundle it's two packs at
50 bucks you get two random packs a lot
of people saying I'm not able to click
we're gonna have to h two random packs
yeah two random packs so there's only 14
of those left those are Android those
are going to go right now it's $50 the
price not showing
it works if you can't if you can't you
got to close out you got to make sure
you have shipping info you make sure you
payment info on your account shipping
and your payment info in your account
have to be there for you able to buy
preloaded if it's not preloaded you're
you're locked out p
and the app everybody can everybody do a
good job for us because obviously these
I know I got you but real quick these
next five packs are going to sell real
quick in the chat because a lot of
people are trying to buy slots for the
upcoming streams please could ogs help
each other and click and explain what to
do I could probably add more afterward
because they're probably going to sell
out we have 600 people here I'll I'll
add more so that shortly after the
stream you'll be able to purchase as
well I just have if you put in your
shipping make sure you go back and
double check because I put in my
shipping saved it it wiped it go back
and double check understood once your
payment and shipping is in there quit
the app relaunch we can't randomize God
that's insane okay here we go so here so
Monday only has 14 spots left at 50 a
piece out of like plus Thursday is two
group breaks 10 boxes each oh they're
sold out are you [__] serious so
those are the most fun ones in my
opinion I'll be honest with random
letter random number are [__] insane
the pins are insan so no pin and super
sticker and super sticker and super
stick and super sticker do you wonder
have you looked at what's going on we
let him go should we let him rip yeah
let him rip let him rip hold on hold on
hold on I'm the one yeah I said yeah
I'll say it in a
minute we have 14 spots left for
tomorrow once those are gone after the
stream we Conor and I will go in like
refresh L tonight people here have not
been following what is actually been
going on I just need people to
understand what's actually been going on
with super stickers on eBay and these
These are these are mostly higher number
than Halloween for sure higher limited
they're at of 499 Halloweens go up to I
want to say 220 might be the say 4.99
499 yeah 90 bucks so what what are the
different rarity levels for the super
stickers in the Halloween packs it
really varies it goes from I want to
think I want to say red double I'm gonna
say this again big I mean tranquil to to
49 look at tranquil to to $4.99 45 bucks
I just want to say big shout out to all
the vriends nft holders actually we got
to get through these because I'm gonna
give away one series two for my
collection and one series one be friends
NF tonight for free for [__] free
several thousand dollars just for for
people don't know I mean I might decide
to give a good one be five six seven 8,
the fun thing here tonight we should
make something clear series 1 nft the
[__] [__] [__] let's make let's
make something clear here the black cat
is in this box it's the gemstone Edition
there's a there's a super sticker that
matches that but it's not like the
official it's the gemstone Edition
sticker so it's technically like a
oneon-one sticker in here all right
let's do this are we about to sell out
these boxes yep when you say go when I
say go everybody if you're ready
just so it's super Fair we're selling
five more boxes here and
[Music]
we and here we go fun fact Gary V has a
song out with new sold
out yeah no that time I couldn't even
see
the I forgot to I forgot to show you how
it I could not have gone
faster I couldn't have gone faster there
is not possibility I could have moved f
F to buy that slot I hit the first I've
always found you SL to be [__] no all
right let's see it no I couldn't have
got this is new one yeah Smitty
Collectibles stinch two three four Big
Easy 3 to one cannabis who has cannabis
what a user and NES 96 I say we start
ripping for Smitty's Collectibles a lot
of people created new accounts tonight
and got great usernames yeah there's a
lot username AR guys one of the great
things for everybody who's on car
Doug hype on YouTube ryum on Twitch
jungly say what's happening is we're on
Fanatics live a new platform for
breaking cards from Fanatics we're doing
the vriends Collectibles right now and
usernames are available people are
getting monster usernames so please get
over uh you might have got a text from
me on 2129315731 my text platform I sent
you a link on Instagram I did an update
on meaningful updates so you got a DM
but if you go to my Twitter right now
there's all the information on how you
get on to the live and for everybody
who's here all 609 of you still here
with us at 1105
p.m. IG live yeah IG live I [__] love
you 200 it's insane all right let open
this back I cannot believe these are
gonna be $25 $24.99 the fact that we
selling these out in one second for 99
the fact gonna be 50 bucks a ComicCon
and on our website but the fact that
only vriends nft holders are all they're
going to be sold out by that crew series
one and series two at 25 bucks for a
super I love that you know because
you're in it a super sticker and a pin
for 25 bucks we wanted to have a
Halloween surprise for the people that
have been [__] rocking with us people
should probably go and get a V Series 2
on open C right the AR might not reach
Series 2 but fair enough irregardless
fair enough wow my phone's getting
second who's up
first wow Harry
Styles's collectibles all
right come on
smitties pull a [__]
monster pull a monster motivated these
are spooky I'm so into these I have to
open these These are [__] amazing
here we go oh it's a
ghost gritty how gritty how gritty if
it's all the same color it's going to
bewin thee dark black yeah it's got a
little Halloween little backstamp I
don't know if you've seen that yet it's
very hard to see on that one show it on
a better
one black hatat backer and a little oh
it's going the dark no it's not it
is it's got for a
minute it's the eyes it's the eyes it's
the all blue eyes that's it that's rarer
than the devil that's R than the
spacular no yes no you got to let it sit
in the light hold it up to the light
hold it up hold it up to the light for
two seconds what the [__] sh
happen wow oh my God it's sick right
[__] sick it's so
sick it can't work [__] can't is that
scientifically how work does that mean
no that's you still do that right so we
can't make go dark stickers it's the
same sticker okay same sticker who the
[__] just got this who how rare is this
rips that is's collectibl I can say how
many there are if we want no I know
don't tell them but it's very rare
that's this right yeah it's rarer than
the
Spooktacular I think people can do the
math
eventually it's very rare [__] it how
many are these
what I'm taking my seat I'm taking my
are you [__] kidding me it's insane
who got
this Smitty charging it up this is so
[__] cool Ty get
in wait shry our pin lock has been
stupid this is ridiculous oh oh [__]
50 only
50 it's actually sick only 50 this is
[__] amazing confirmed 50 50 how we
pull two robots and the ghost got the
stickers to 499 because we could do we
could do some slight we could do some
who the [__] just got Smitty's
Collectibles Smitty's colec how much is
this not for me to say but okay here's
here's another tidbit of alpha
is that this is the rarest of the
glow-in-the-dark ghost variants from
ComicCon little something GNA be
confused couple just post a [__] blog
post on Friday I don't [__]
understand here we go wow holy [__]
there's only 50 of them smitties
congratulations what a let's I need
loud the fact that Smitty went for the
99 I mean these are going to be 50 and
25 and he went for the 99 because of the
Box signing and then [__] pulled it
are you [__] kidding won the SL all
right let's
go I can't believe that I had a feeling
I had a feeling it's pretty easy you
could either pop also gets the void
it's I don't know how I thought it was
going to be the ghost going dark because
I didn't think there's GNA be two ghosts
in the same like back to back but there
oh it's a spacular
sticker oh my
God je somebody just got it's it's it's
got and it's got a spec black cat
compared to the other black cats on the
back holy [__] it's got like the black
cat spec oh I see somebody just pulled a
spook tackler the first ever how many
this the first time we're ever SE I've
never seen it the amount of I've never
seen
it this is
insane who got this
SD DCH s DCH DCH there's six different
spectaculars oh it's the bubble gu
smooth
spider oh my God God are you [__]
kidding me so there's six colors to
collect because V friends has six
spectacular oneon-one variants are you
[__] this is the bubblegum kidding me
right
now let's see that that's hot oh my gosh
it looks just like the nfts because it's
that black background I like what you do
was yeah the rainbow
spacular so detail you know how much
this is going to go there's only 99 of
these SP all spectaculars out of 999
it's just like Uno I think so for the
ogs there's it's there's six pins each
character only comes in one color so
it's not like there's six different
spiders they're all bubblegum spiders
it's all I guess people see we just pull
a [__] a [__] glow-in-the dark
ghost and then a [__] back to back
and two robots this is pin night little
did we know this would become pin night
pin sane we got to be careful that
[__] pity I feel like this case
incredible they us be care
that this cat might float out that would
be so bad it's like when you open the
Zer box you open the zero cool box and
the I can who got this this pin is so
[__] nasty yeah that's a good way
let's show the stamp on Von pins that
there's a ton of there's not that many
of the Vons but that's true yeah it's
pretty limited are there only 99 does
that means yeah every pin and sticker
matches Supply wise that's 100% show the
back because you got that little
Halloween badge
glow are you [__] kidding me bubble
gum recess
metal wow that is wow bizarre I'm shook
this is beautiful some saying they'd
cover them skate their skate here we go
we can't I don't know if we can get much
better number eight number eight I feel
bad Big Easy three to
one time
pissed yeah so the back I guess the back
of them is different on the Spooktacular
it's got the whole Spooktacular and
rainbow getting this is so
sick oh you know what that is yes I do
one of your
favorites let's [__] go one of my
favorite be BRS The Fearless fairy SI
who got this this is Big Easy this
sticker is unreal this sticker e a good
one you you made this background I know
yeah that was a lot that was on a flight
I was like rips you [__]
changeed this to this you're like it was
originally candy corn like what you do
you made a typo it's like corn
blows rips I'm on a flight to like
[__] Brazil rips shows this to me I
look at I'm like corn it was candy corn
background on a sticker and I'm like
rips corn blow
and now it's the new one which looks way
hotter oh oh
yeah so sick it's got like a nice Barber
Shop flow in the back to 3.99 huh a
little bit more rare this Barber Shop
flow like swirl could be like the super
sticker background permanently and I'd
be so happy about it I agree it's harder
to see on the camera no you could get a
little something yeah this is [__]
fire yeah it's h this is one of the best
ones honestly
wow this is
[__] here's the thing if you're
watching the super stickers are becoming
one of the most sought after
collectibles in all of V friends and the
fact there's only 399 of these Fearless
stickers period I don't know to tell you
that's it [__] huge the rounded
Corners these are like I agree Sunset
cards you do need to get 30 stickers for
your deck are wow all right fair I agree
teacher who you know I love Tom Cat he's
a he's Tom cat's the best he just said
best sticker yet I don't disagree with
him all right this is for cannabis
cannabis we have any cannabis related
characters here no tranquil toad no he's
not Halloween he's not
Halloween wow this is [__]
fun for canis no not on
Halloween for
cannabis oh oh I see what it is nice you
love that one too I'm [__] obset I
also want to pick it also has like the
competitive nice the
competitive clown clown I this sticker
this the only sticker with the same I
think it's the same background Jeremy
theme I'm
ready here we go the fives uh nft
holders discount at ComicCon no only on
the website correct before ComicCon
hopefully yes hopefully should be should
be so no at Comic Con just too much with
the POs
but be friends holders can prove it on
the website should be good but at
Comic-Con they're 50 bucks these this
sticker is also crazy this sticker is
bananas holy [__] that's too cool that
pose is awesome it's got that same
swirly Barber Shop background as the
fairy uh I don't know if people are
paying attention there's only 199 sh
shoot rare this is gon be one of the
most sought after stick this super
sticker graded is gonna be Tyler 4% 4%
there's only gonna be 199 clown pins and
super stickers this is the thing the pin
journey and the super sticker journey to
getting through every character I'm
gonna drop some Alpha tonight Tyler calm
down one there will be exclusives in
other countries you and I are working on
that there will be super stickers that
are only available in Canada and so the
people in Canada are going to be able to
get it and whatever mechanic we're going
to do and people are like that's huge
there're going to be super stickers that
are only available in Australia down
under far from America you will only be
able to get them in Australia and then
thus those people will be able to have
this arbit people are gonna be be be
buying flights AIA no it's gonna the
people there are going to be able to
make huge arbitrages and there's only of
course or people walk into an Australia
shop in the like yeah but more
importantly these characters are off the
board The Fearless Ferry the resilient
Red Devil the [__] zombie this
motivated monster he's some of the
biggest characters in our universe off
the board Halloween is Major at be
friends we got big announcements coming
up we did the burn Island on the parade
that's [__] nuts vriends is going to
be an official float in the New York
City Halloween parade do you understand
Tyler the the pin trading there is gonna
be sick this is insane everyone's gonna
have their pins by then all right man
they look really good in person here we
go much better last
one for n96
new 996 the final
box the final box of
the you get a spot what's great about
these I'll say before we pop this open
compared to Von oh Von was 20 pins in a
sealed case and there were only 12
characters so everyone's getting like
two or three duplicates four or five
duplicates these we have 15 characters
but only 10 pins 14 characters without
the black hat only 10 pins in a box so
the dup like it's just a way better set
way better set way better set speaking
of way better sick how many of you are
well connected cuz the werewolf don't
give no [__] feeling n
is this guy's [__]
amazing are you [__] kidding me so
cool that's [__] amazing werewolf 6%
pretty rare on that what's 299 299 it's
got little crescent moons in the back
that's to 299 yeah look at those moons
little crescent moons har
Moon Wow Let's pop it up for all the
winners what a
night I kept a bunch of stuff but I also
got smokes
smokes let's give away this heart pick
for free what let's go what we're giving
away a harick for free right now free
giveaway for everybody who's been
hanging all 600 of these people deserve
it free harpic
ccile oh the Hustler the to see you in
the chat everybody who's paying
attention on my social media platforms
get over to Fanatics live I texted you I
hit you up on a DM on Instagram go to my
Twitter right now you got to get over
here we need way more people in and for
the 575 that have hung because a couple
people have dropped off I don't know if
you know this I've been slow playing it
but there is another entire
box no you're kidding there is an entire
another box of 10
Max of the be
friends I was suppos to photograph these
tomorrow morning Zack Wilson damn it do
you need the you need this for
Photograph um okay we won't have to do
it today I might have the yeah no no we
won't do it sorry you're welcome
Carrie looking who got it looking
looking
handle great handle good handle 11:20 at
night you said we're here till 3: so we
have time you need no brother I have to
I have a 6 a.m. workout all right we're
giving away
this set it up H $100 bill some I need
to do it we're just doing
it I'm shipping it to you in the mail
shipped in a penny
top
have you signed $100
before leave it leave it 47 seconds
somebody's literally just clicking a
button to get $100 in the mail guys this
is what we do have be friends I need the
comments saying let's [__] go be
friends let's go baby let's [__] go
be
friends currency grading is legit here
we go $100
bill bucks do Penny sleeved and topl
loaded Dustin
then's right here Dustin desperately
needs it is worth a haunted at least you
know who's worth a haunted you know
who's worth
Aon this is hilarious no what's
hilarious is we preceded the Halloween
announcement sold some boxes they're
[__] amazing pin super sticker 25
bucks who
W all right let's wrap it up with this
here we go this is what's up next that's
to
funny a series 2 vend that's sitting in
my wallet right
now A Series 2 vfriend
nft the real [__] these Collectibles are
derivatives the Real Collectibles for V
friends and forever are the first ones
that came out which is first series one
next the mini drops from gift goats
series two I'm giving away with
with concierge handholding over Zoom to
set up your wallet to teach you how to
do it
the whole nine from the vriends team on
how to set it up obviously some of you
might win that know how to do it but a
series two beend of my choice in my
wallet right now giveaway hit it someone
right now is getting an nft and when
they win please let me know if you own a
vfriend or not we want to know right now
vriend Series 2 NF is it a go or is it
something you could have bought uh it's
probably something I bought because it's
sitting in my hot wallet and I just want
to be able to ship it to someone right
away so it's not a
go nft get into the B's nft Community
let me know if you own any vends simple
as that do you own a VR nft yes or no
let's start now yes or no just real
comments yes or no by the way the only
way the only way that these box existed
was with get buying an nft oh I know I'm
just telling the chat I know you know 38
seconds away I think we sold out of all
of our slots people said in the comments
yeah we have to list more after we get
off we have nothing left yeah guys let
us know on Twitter what you want to see
break format wise if you haven't gotten
a chance to join a break you want to
join let us we'll definitely list more
within an hour a half hour by the way
we're gonna be wrapping up here soon
we're gonna end with
this and then I'm gonna walk home and
I'm gonna go on Twitter and I need all
your comments on what you thought about
tonight feedback comments how much fun
you had all of it the reality is is
tonight was a special
night is always big
special
please Zach do something Sunday Night
Football we have nothing we have nothing
available at all everything sold out
yeah the Halloween stuff is sick sick I
think we [__] up by doing 50% off
holders it's now 10% off who what
flj you have
n flj please let us know if you own oh I
flj does own one right I never heard I
don't know that thing doesn't ring a
bell to me Jerry no flj please leave a
comment and let us know if you own a
Bend's nftp if you own any uh uh nfts
would love to know if we just onboarded
someone to a digital collectible these
digital Collectibles known as nfts are
in the same era right now posts the
website stock drop in that lull when
people are razing and making fun but
rise like a forever Phoenix and created
a new world all right here we go one
this is my first time nice
nice we'll be in
touch I'm really happy
forj we will be we will be contacting
you right we can get to them through the
app yeah we'll be contacting you
tomorrow we'll get you a coner White
Glove service someone that will set you
up with how you get a wallet how you get
digital wallet I'll transfer it to you
we're gonna teach you the whole game I'm
really excited about it if he follows us
on Twitter too we could DM them there
we'll get to it'll get we'll get to you
we'll get to you oh
shoot sign it for tomorrow you guys are
doing no you can sign it for tomorrow
let do that tomorrow what everybody's
been waiting for 11:25 PM two hours 25
minutes of this live stream for you to
get and I know this is the Holy Grail
somebody right now will be getting a
series one vfriend of my
choice likely AO not guaranteed I got to
work through Andy and the
details but right here right now one of
the 609 of you yeah this is not a
[__] this is it right now no
employees are eligible relax
Dustin Tyler right now the how is very
easy here it is the big the biggest
thing of the night the Holy Grail of you
haven't given away a go series one in a
very long time this is AB huge you you
have it's absurd you held back 10% or so
from The Collection it's absurd absurd
and honestly I'm in the mood you know
how piss I'm send I'm going to send a
good one too to just [__] stick it
know how piss be 68 people that aren't
going to get it right now I know people
are thousands and thousands people are
watching at home watch this here we
go be friends series one nft of my
choice launched this is this is what
happens when people stick around what a
night we did the end of the stream this
is what happens when you hang
what happens so happy God I really want
this for someone what if it's someone
want it to be some you never heard of
whoever it's happiness honestly all 612
people that are here right now with us
are family the 300 the 300,000 other
people who didn't come to the live
stream are going to be pissed I'm so mad
at rips I was gonna sell these for 200
bucks a pack and they were gonna be sold
in two seconds but he's like I Ain a pH
out I Ain a pH
out we can figure it out I don't I'm not
opposed anymore
he did this is like the biggest I
actually like it we're not doing it I
want these [__] sticker pins to be so
absurdly high demand I want people three
entries on 6 that is this should be
10,000 Zs this is insane this is insane
good luck everybody good luck everybody
I got the roller here this is
crazy this one matters oh what
crazy won he won
before customer
loyalty he said Redemption WHYY guy
congratulations wisy guy do you own a
nft we need to know we need to know I'm
watching I'm also curious if you knew
about V friends before Fanatics live
because it's not a familiar name to me
yes a V2 he has a
V2 not anymore one congratulations wow
congratulations ear the
Halloween I gotta be honest with you we
can do it I think this has become the
biggest thing in the game we're not
doing it okay we're gonna make people
want the bottom line is get your ass to
the Javit Center go buy a vriend series
2 or series one if you really want it's
probably I would be shocked if we got
the series two shock got it go buy a
series one be friend if you want this or
go on eBay because people are flipping
that's what we do here this vcon hat I
know you guys are gonna give this away
are you are you streaming tomorrow
tomorrow yeah tomorrow no I'm gonna sign
this all sold out proving all every
stream is sold out Pro prove the
signature you and I will talk
tonight uh little something oh yeah
beon we got to add We'll add more to the
to our we haven't even listed Halloween
stuff I think we could weit a little
more we got we haven't list like
whatever we listed sold out announced
day this is so cool people are gonna go
crazy for that is got in just thetics
account Indianapolis was an indie little
race car hat that
is we've been doing this straight and a
half hours and I want to do this for the
next 4 hours but I have to go 6 a
workout Mike Mike vonti flew in from
Minnesota we're doing in person need a
little in person yeah but really quick
just for [__] kicks and giggles I'm
giving away this right here signed alien
wizard mini toy Alpha wizard mini toy
empathy elephant with the fives in the
feet are you [__] kidding me this
little three pack right here let's give
it away for free con I like what you're
doing in and you know what I'm actually
GNA also throw in a
perfect those are so hard to get I know
pristine for my collection by the way a
pristine awesome couple easy pristines
are always a couple hundred bucks that's
not even a monster character but launch
here we go here we go followers only
I'll use this minute to wrap up the show
as we give this away thank you for being
here tonight all 600 you that stayed the
whole time Tyler great energy team in
the back love you guys thank you so much
for
jamming let's
go I gotta be honest with you I'm
freaking the [__] out on the Halloween
[__] Halloween bro a [__] are you
kidding me a [__] I gave away a 100
bucks for no reason tonight that's hilar
I gave away my first appearance Deadpool
comic graded 96 oh I forgot about it no
we had a great night I mean this is more
fun than watching some like clicking
through Netflix trying to find some
[__] this is 10 times better thank
you everybody please tell your friends
thank you everybody who was on my other
platforms Bobby kleene the twitch Mafia
on here Brian cholle all of you I love
you all I want to thank Z wson for what
he's gonna do on Sunday night in stun
the Chiefs and Taylor [__] Swift and
her [__] face who won tonight this is
huge this is a nice little F great
giveaway in that part of it it's a nice
little and the winner
is Bonsai Hunter Bonsai Hunter
Bonsai as we wrap up the show thank you
for tuning in we have a stream tomorrow
I know all the slots are sold out for
everything we're doing we will
strategize Monday and Thursday Mond
refresh the streets that's how people
really we're gonna figure out do some
other stuff we know the I'm I'm already
getting texts on my phone the Halloween
[__] I know get to the jabit center own
a vfriend series one the arm is real
they're going to be 50 retail if they
even get out there 25 bucks we [__] it
I'm a little bit upset we [__] it up
let's stop it it's over 55 we completely
[__] up $25 for super sticker at a pin
if you want to [__] V but that's what
we're supposed to be doing right Jerm
that's what we should be doing I came to
you I came to you with the higher price
you're like let's slice it for the
holders look I want it to be right by I
really want V series one
is my continued
Obsession huge news tomorrow follow my
socials and follow everything else we
will be announcing the dates which are
interesting I did something clever they
will not be the same weekend that's the
ear That's The Late Late Late Alpha um
for beon
um I'm really excited October is gonna
be a massive month we have a lot of
other announcements we have some really
fun announcements I hope you had a lot
of fun I hope you enjoyed the free
giveaways here's what I last of all five
71 of you here and the people that are
watching on my other channels I'm
literally getting up right now G to hug
it out with the crew and walk home I'm
gonna read my Twitter please go to
Twitter uh garbe as most of you know
please let me know what you thought
about tonight observations I know it's X
but it's Twitter to me.com cards please
everyone go to bends. comom cards if you
want to learn more about what's going on
please go to eBay check out
vriends I'm just enjoying this so much
we'll be doing this a lot thank you so
much for tuning in have a great night
get some sleep get some rest we'll see
you next time did we say who won
those yeah bons Hunters B Hunters right
thank you everybody thank you
guys are you stopping the stream I can
still see the stream on the other
platforms doing that now bye